let me say quite genuinely that you do
your your questions are some of the best
um
they target very important areas and no
i think you're
you know from that point of view you're
one of the best interviewers that i've
come across so thank you i could talk to
you all day i wish we had time
ian mcgillcrist is a psychiatrist a
writer and a former oxford scholar
who came into prominence after the
publication of his book master and its
emissary which is a fantastic book by
the way
links are in the description this book
is about the fundamental realities we
experience that are different
complementary yet incompatible and
rooted in the by-hemispheric structures
of the brain each time i think i can't
top a podcast
somehow the guest surprises me and ian
is no different
we touch on the problem of the modern
world with its overemphasis on
rational mechanistic explanations while
it simultaneously
s choose meaning we also talk about
consciousness
and how can one be a moral person if
there are no objective truths are there
objective truths we also talk about
schizophrenia and i get
fairly personal in this interview and
the reason is that
i am driven by the screenwriting adage
which says
the more general the pain the less
personal it is and the more
personal the pain the more general it is
this means that ultimately people will
relate more to someone speaking their
experience earnestly
and candidly rather than generic
platitudes
unfortunately there were connectivity
issues with zoom as usual
and some of his points were crushed
omitted or overly compressed
there's very little that can be done
about this because for whatever reason
the backup recording on ian's end
stopped if you would like to contribute
to watching or listening
to more conversations like this then
please consider visiting
patreon.com slash kurt jaymungal every
dollar helps not only financially but
motivationally
thank you so much enjoy
i've heard about your book i don't
remember exactly where i heard about
your book master and it's emissary and i
believe i even came to watch the film
version of it maybe one of the first
screenings of it where you had some
laptop trouble
and you were skyping live to us the
movie was
was okay but the book the movie doesn't
sell the book
the book is a fascinating fascinating
it's a it's
it's a frightening book at least i find
it to be so i find it to be unnerving
and subversive we can talk about why i
find it
to be that later this channel is about
theories of everything and
usually that involves talking to
physicists string theories included and
so on and so on but
um the way that i conceptualize the
theory of everything is
there's no english word for it there's a
german word it's called veltan
that means a framework through which to
interpret the world
it's like it's more than a world view a
world view would be not selling it
properly and i believe you have a
i believe you have a veltan xiaong and
it's
yes it's well
i don't know how you did it i also i
also have a gaza
[Laughter]
what's that a theory of everything
okay well this is a great time to give
the audience
a quick recapitulation of your main
thesis of the master and its emissary
yes
effectively people think
that they noticed there was a difference
between the two halves of the brain
in the late 19th century and then this
took a step forward in the 1960s and 70s
with the first split brain operations
in california
in which people's brains were surgically
severed in the middle the connection
between the two halves of the bearing
the corpus callosum
was severed and so it was possible to
interrogate and to investigate one
hemisphere at a time
and a number of theories arose out of
that and most of them are now considered
wrong
and correctly they're considered wrong
but the problem that we have to
rather different hemispheres doesn't go
away why
if the brain gets its power from making
connections
should there be an enormous divide right
down the middle of it
and this is not just for humans this is
for all animals to be studied
they all have an asymmetrical neuronal
network
with some kind of division between the
parts so
i set about investigating that and
it occurred to me that what was the
difference was the need to pay attention
to the world in two different ways at
once
and that's a very important point
because how we attend to things
changes what we find not just whether
we're aware of them
but the quality of the awareness changes
what it is that we find there
and it also changes us who are doing the
finding
so attention is a moral act it creates
or destroys
different ways they will bring into
being two different
versions if you like of reality and
i then started investigating 20 30 years
what these differences were and
effectively they aren't what people used
to say they used to think it was
you know as you think of a machine well
what does it do
well the left hemisphere does language
and reason and the right hemisphere does
pictures and emotion but this is not
right since all these things
are looked after by both hemispheres but
we should have asked a different
question if we've been thinking in terms
of a living being instead of a machine
instead of asking what does it do as
though it's just a functional utility
we'd ask in what manner how does it do
it
and to what sort of end because things
evolve
in in living beings
in ways that answer to existential needs
to be
able to carry on being so and i think
there is an answer to that that we do
need in order to
be able to pay attention to little
details of things which is mainly things
that we're going to use like
food or you know if you're a bird
picking up a twig to build a nest or
catching your prey you need a certain
kind of attention that doesn't really
need to know the whole picture it just
needs to know the little tiny bit in the
middle of the picture which is
very highly focused on but if it's only
paying that kind of attention
it will not survive because it will
become prey to another creature very
quickly so it needs to have
a different attention which is a broad
open attention
and a sustained attention now
that that's a very you know a very brief
remark but on it hangs just about
everything
because because these two ways of
attending
bring about two different valtteri they
bring about two different ways of
looking at the world
in one there are things that we can use
and they're essentially fragmented one
from another
we can pick them up they're isolated we
put them together to make things that we
want
and it has no meaning and it's not
really connected to us but we can
manipulate it and that's the left
hemispheres picture
the left hemisphere enables us to
manipulate the world
and in survival terms that's obviously
very important but it doesn't help us
understand the world at all
the right hemisphere mean time which
doesn't usually have access to speech
it contributes to language but it for
most of us doesn't actually speak
is seeing a completely different world
one in which things
are never entirely isolated or atomistic
they're
interconnected they are in fact
everything is connected to everything
else
ultimately and it's a a field that is
changing
all the time it's not just made up of
things that sit in the field
it's the whole field of things that we
see and perceive
and we relate to it we don't sort of see
it as a thing and then relate to it
it comes into being through our
relationship with it
so that built into it is the idea of
relation
and so this is a very very different
world and it sees things as
special unique that's
that's a thing we might come back to
because people might say but surely if
they're unique then
what's this about them being all
interconnected but it seems to me the
whole
business is to be able to maintain
together uniqueness and individuation
with togetherness without collapsing
into fragmentation and
atomism so it sees a world made up of
unique individuals that that are
constantly changing it sees all the
stuff that's implicit
left hemisphere understands only
understands the most explicit stuff
this is the world that we live in every
day nowadays
it's nobody picks up the messages and if
you do they become something quite
different
try explaining a joke try explaining a
poem try explaining a piece of music
you can't because it is an experience in
which all the important stuff is
implicit
and so of course is the whole realm of
what we seem to have completely
abandoned the idea of there being
a sacred world a a divine element in the
cosmos
these things don't make sense to the
left hemisphere it seems obviously a
mistake
but that's because it hasn't seen so
much of the picture
anyway i'll leave it there and you can
ask me some questions
you mentioned that the right hemisphere
is involved in understanding
and understanding your meaning okay what
does meaning mean
well yes a very good question
there are any word you like the left
hemisphere has one idea which on the
right hand is for a different one
so to the left hemisphere meaning is
something that is as you might expect
put together
from bits and it could be something we
create by
you know words are tokens they're put
together by
systematic uh syntax and
they turn into a meaning the computer
might be able to find out of the
combination of a dictionary and a book
of grammar rules
but meaning is not that when i say
that there is meaning in certain
experiences
like the you know my my wife means
everything to me
or this piece of music means so much
or you know just being able to walk in
wilderness is so
important and it brings meaning to
things
now what i want to stress is that
nowadays when people
allow that there could be meaning coming
from certain experiences
they see that as an invention
of ours so we do this and we think okay
now we've added some meaning
but that's not the image that's the left
hemisphere image of something that is
added
to something else mechanically what i'm
saying is
we are in certain experiences made to be
more receptive
more aware of something that is there to
be brought into being through the
commerce between
ourselves our own consciousness and
whatever it is that
we're conscious of so it's a relational
thing
absolutely at its core is relation and
at its core it's consciousness
so in this way i found that you're a
physicist
that surprisingly a lot of physicists
have written to me since the master and
this emissary was published
saying this is very important and
interesting from our point of view
and in the book that i've just finished
and want to publish in the next few
months called the matter with things
i take three ways of looking at the
world one is
neuro science one
is philosophy and the third is physics
and i show that quite coherently by
pursuing each of these powers
we can come to a vision of a picture of
the world
which is very very different from the
one
that we're taught and that which the
popular media
and the the vox pop of sort of
scientists who
do too much talking and not enough
thinking i would suggest
something that impresses me to an
extreme amount about your book
at least though i've only i've only read
the master and it's emissary
in that one it's quite a tome and
you see someone you don't just see them
compile chapters together you see them
work through their life
in these pages and i'm wondering okay
how did you go about doing this because
it seems like to me there's a plethora
of data
at first you have to just accumulate and
dispassionately view
so that you don't bias it beforehand
with your own worldview
and then you had to cohere somehow what
you saw
into a unified message how long
was the researching process and then how
long from once you started
did you find enough of a through line
that you're like i can legitimately
start writing instead of just
researching
yes well it's easy to say about the
gathering of the data
that took about 20 years um
but really the
the core of the idea was that i
felt already that there were two kinds
of
ways we could think about the world two
kinds of awareness of it that we
we both we needed both and we use both
and as always it's not either that you
just
collect data and then look at it and
something happens
nor is it that uh you have an idea and
you collect the data just to support it
it's like everything it's a kind of
an encounter a rapprochement coming
together of two things that sense each
other's
existence as to loving people
uh understand come to understand one
another and
as indeed we understand the sacred and
the divine it's a coming together of
something that speaks to us and we speak
to it and if you don't speak to it you
won't hear anything back from it
so you most people
in think that science is made out of
just doing hundreds and
thousands of tests and then following an
entirely logical path but in fact
a lot of great scientists have pointed
out that what happens is you have
intuitions of a shape
of something that is you know you can't
put your finger on it but you know
there's something here
and you start to look at the data and
you find that some of the data fit with
it but some of the data don't
and that's really important and
interesting because then
you say okay i was thinking of it like
this now i see i need to accommodate
this other thing
so for 20 years or 25 years this is what
i did
i saw things and i changed what i
thought
it evolved as all things evolve
the whole cosmos evolves evolution isn't
just something that darwin spotted in
animals
evolution is being being is becoming
and this is a cosmos that is becoming
not one that is just static and being
so that process of creation was like all
processes of creation
the sensing of something that at the
moment you can't put your finger on
like a painter doesn't know exactly
where all the bits in the painting are
going to go
when he or she starts it the poet
doesn't know
exactly but here's certain the shape of
a few lines some images
and then it starts to grow from that so
science is not
different or opposite to
different from or opposite to the
creative arts it is in fact
very similar to the creative arts is
there a reason why god is associated
with
becoming rather than being or rather
than a combination of both becoming and
being
well there are as many ideas of god as
there are
you know traditions in the world and
probably as many as there are people
so ideas about god can be very different
but i have noted a very interesting
strain
in the mythologies and anthropologies
of peoples around the world from
china and india from um
[Music]
from the circumpolar regions from
the native american peoples and so on
that speak
of a world that is becoming not just
made but is constantly coming into being
and i think that ultimately
you can bring together the idea of a god
that is
eternally and a god that is coming into
being
but if i had to put my money on one or
the other it would be the coming into
being it seems to me that that is
utterly primary
and interestingly people like paulie and
heisenberg and
and uh scherdinger and so forth in the
20th century
thought similarly that becoming was more
important than being
david boehm said that as well and i
think niels bohr
okay this reminds me of another line
from your book and it could be you said
the mind or the brain i don't regret i
don't remember which one
which we can talk about what's the
difference between the mind and the
brain but regardless
you said either the mind or the brain
it's not correct to think of it as the
brain
slash mind is grappling with the world
but instead it's bringing the world
about
okay now to some that conflates the
objective world with the
phenomenological one
so i'm wondering can you explain what
you mean when you say it brings the
world about
well i may not be able to explain it
very well in language because i think
our language is not very well suited to
describing
reality it's very well suited to
describing
everyday things like getting lunch and
uh
building a wall but when it comes to
actually understanding what we're
dealing with
we don't necessarily have the words for
it and you know bohr himself said there
is no way we can talk about
physics eventually except in the
language of poetry and he said the same
thing is true
of um philosophy and and of
the talking about the divine or whatever
it is so
yes what i've struggled with very much
is not collapsing into one or other of
two major areas of our age
one is to say quite simply it's all made
up by us so it's like we're sitting in a
little
um cinema inside our heads and sitting
on the sofa little homunculus watching
the scene but we have no contact with
the world of
anything else out there and the other is
that you know
just the world is out there and it's
just a matter of going out measuring it
photographing it and you've got it
so you know in one case you've got very
simplistic materialism and in the other
you've got very simplistic idealism
and i don't think that either of these
positions
uh gets us very far i think the
important thing is to see these bridges
because as i say
everything is actually connected and
it's through the connection
that they come into being so let me
say that again because it's something
that again as a physicist you will
understand you probably know david
merman the physicist
he says relations
are prior to relata now i was delighted
when i heard that
because i have been working on that
basis for most of my adult life
and that sounds nonsense to most people
how can relations exist before there are
things that relate
but actually the things only become what
they are in the process of the
relationship
indeed we only are what we are as human
beings in the process of the many
relationships we have
with other people and with the world at
large
and there's an image in the vedic
tradition which i like very much of
indra's net
and indra's net is a cosmic uh
net that covers the whole world
and in it at every place where the
threads cross there is a little jewel
and in this jewel it reflected all the
other jewels and the whole of the net
so it's like a hologram in a way but
what is fabulous about it
is that they point out that the threads
the connections
exist before any of the points that make
a net the things that make it a net are
the crossings
that's what we see but they just stand
forward after
interesting uh the relations have done
what they are so i think it's a good
image because
i think we tend to focus on certain
things that stand forward to us
in the world immediately and neglect the
background out of which they emerge and
from which they're never separate
and this is a very basic
neuropsychological
distinction between the left and right
hemisphere which you can demonstrate in
the lab any day
the left hemisphere sees a single thing
of interest that is foregrounded
and it ignores the rest whereas the
right hemisphere sees the whole
scene with whatever it is embedded in it
now this reminds me
of in one of your talks you were talking
about it was an offhand comment you said
that
existence is predicated on resistance
and so what i'm wondering is
is this resistance akin to a relation
yes but it's not the same thing
but without some degree of resistance
without some degree
of opposition
nothing comes into being nothing can do
anything i mean in a very simple way
motion is only made possible because of
friction which is the
thing that itself brings motion to a
standstill
so i mean i know that's a folk sort of
idea but i think it's helpful
that actually what comes into being is
shaped
it's not just formless there are forms
that shape
what comes into being and we our minds
partake of those and of course any form
any shape
is already a denial of something else
because
if it didn't deny or negate anything
it would be just a formless chaos a bag
of nothing
because it would be everything and
everything would be nothing because
there'd be no differentiation of
anything from anything else nothing
would exist
right or everything you have to exclude
you have to you have to exclude you have
to
limit and that is the process of
resistance
and you know there are lots of ways in
which you can think of this but there's
one that i like particularly if you're
going to talk about
consciousness because i believe that our
consciousness
your consciousness my consciousness is
not entirely separate
from other consciousnesses
but for the while it is shaped
uh by whatever form it is that our
consciousness is
instantiated in and william james who
i think is one of the towering
intellects of the last
couple of hundred years said about this
that
it is like the breath passing over his
vocal cords
that if there were no vocal cords the
breath would say nothing
it would mean nothing but because there
are vocal cords that
restrict it it becomes the voice that is
him
so i think you know we can you can allow
that
to germinate in your imagination but i
think the point is
that things are not isolated by
resistance but actually strengthened by
and come into being by resistance let me
just mention another
very interesting small insight
you know there are these uh to get their
golden but these
eco domes in which plants
some of them are very large plants are
grown in a protected environment under
glass biosphere some of them are
biospheres that's it thank you um
and people were puzzled to begin with
that trees in these biospheres
kept falling over before they had any
maturity
and it turned out that trees in order to
grow
properly need wind they need wind to
blow them
and challenge them and they they produce
a core of strength in the wood
and in their roots which enables them to
thrive
there we are it's just another image of
the same thing
let's talk about the title of your book
the master in its emissary which i
believe is derived from the nietzschean
story
in the nichian story the emissary is
contemptuous of the master
now that has me wondering does the left
hemisphere
have some emotional reason that it
thinks that it
is primal or that it has an emotional
reason to usurp the right brain because
people normally associate emotion with
the right and the left is just
calculating
well it's interesting because all those
things that people used to say
that they're just you know emotions in
one hemisphere that is
entirely wrong as i say what is
different is the way
so they each have emotions they just
have different ways of relating to the
world
and interestingly the emotion that most
lateralizes is anger
and it lateralizes to the left
hemisphere not to the right
it's tempting um
and not perhaps entirely wrong since
after all
the brain is part of a person to think
of these two hemispheres as having
personalities of a kind
um i mean of course one immediately
invites the
past that you know everyone's
anthropomorphizing a
a computer or something but of course
one's easy easily sort of
skewing the picture by thinking of the
brain as a computer because it's
obviously part of a living person as
well
anyway um to cut a long story short yes
uh when when you isolate one hemisphere
at a time
the left hemisphere is more confident
even when it's entirely wrong
and tends to increase its sense of
conviction when it's presented with data
that suggests that it might be wrong
whereas the right hemisphere
tends to be more um more open to
well it might be something different
actually ramachandran you know
very well known neuroscientist says um
that
he calls it the the um the devil's
advocate
the right hemisphere because well the
left hemisphere is jumping to
conclusions which it does
very quickly the right hemisphere is
going yes but on the one hand and on the
other
and you know another element that we
miss very much in today's
culture is that the ability to nuance
physician
opinions and see this good and bad in
many things
that more and more of something you
think is good is not necessarily good
and so forth
but to come back to the hemispheres
it's also true that the left hemisphere
sees less i mean it literally sees less
uh in the sense of it attends to less
and therefore takes in less of the world
and when you see or or understand less
you think you know it all right there's
uh a phenomenon in
psychology called the dunning-kruger
effect which basically is that when
people are very bright
they think they don't know very much but
when they're stupid they think they know
everything
and so it's the people who are at least
intelligent who are most dogmatic
about their views and i think that
you could say that the left hemisphere
suffers from not really understanding
jumping to conclusions and tending to be
rather impatient and angry
um so yes i think you could you could
say that about them and what
what i've been amazed by is in how many
cultures
there is a story like the master in his
emissary
of two brothers or
an emperor and his general or whatever
it is
these two powers and one of them is
clearly
sort of superintendent of the other but
the
the other thinks that it should be the
master
even though it doesn't really understand
what it's doing and it
tries to resist and even to try to
destroy
that force now that that story exists in
iroquois
legends it exists in chinese
8th century literature you know it's
it's there
all around the world it's there in
inward mythology
what is this that we're seeing i think
it is an understanding
that there is a part of us that is
somehow unwilling to accept um
that it knows very little
and if only more people einstein
actually said in the letter to the queen
of belgium
he said if more people understood how
very little we know the world would be a
much nicer place to live in
speaking of stories i'm reminded of one
by hildegard the bingham
it's one of my favorite quotes i'm not
sure if you're aware of it but it goes
something like this
and pride germinated in the first angel
as he
could no longer comprehend the source of
his own light and so he spoke to himself
i want to be master and want none above
me and that one is powerful
i think about that often because in one
so the first angel satan
and then two through his own radiance he
couldn't comprehend the source of his
own light and then three
and so he spoke to himself and so he
spoke to himself
and that to me is there's something
about being overly self-conscious and
and just simply speaking to yourself and
not talking to others
that breeds well it it reinforces
arrogance but it also wants you
there's something there's something evil
about it
yes i'm interested that you use that
word
most people these days are frightened of
using it
having spent a long time as a
psychiatrist i've certainly seen
sickness and i've seen unhappiness but i
have also
at times seen evil
something that is not fueled by any need
or anything except the desire to destroy
and to hurt
and i think that does exist in all
cultures people
have thought that he did and that it's
probably not just confined to us
so i mean the absolute locus classicus
in the west is
milton's paradise lost which is whose
theme is entirely this
because of course it was lucifer the
lightbringer as the name means
who became the chief of the of the
devils
and in that sense he was exactly like
the emissary to the master because in
the story of that
the reason the master points the
emissary is that he's
such a good emissary the trouble is he's
not a very good master
and this this unequal dynamic is very
important and i think it's very
difficult people to understand these
days
because we'd like to think in a rather
left hemisphere way that things should
be just symmetrical
that if there's a and b they should be
just symmetrical but they may not be one
of them may be much more important and
creative than the other
so i think these drives if you like that
are in things
are are different not necessarily easily
reconciled
um and this has nothing to do with a
particularly religious point of view i
i'm
sorry to say that i don't really i mean
i certainly honor religions and
spiritual
traditions but i i don't myself feel
that i have any
particular connection to to the divine
but i do
i would hate to lose the sense that
there is something
beyond the material that is very
important and powerful and beautiful
in this world
part of why your book is so fascinating
is there are sentences
embedded within paragraphs which are
already far-reaching implications
so there's a set of three sentences i
don't recall where
somewhere chapter seven chapter eight i
wish i had written them down but i just
wrote down
a note what you've done in these three
sentences is connect
nihilism borderism sorry boredom the
platonic realm of timelessness
and then to me that also connects
eastern mysticism and then the idea of
the present moment
as for the exact connection the
relations between those i'm still
cogitating i'm still trying to
understand but you said that
in an almost an offhand with an offhand
remark and i was wondering i don't know
if you realize the profundity
of those statements
i don't remember actually the words but
i could have said something like that
definitely
i i know i say which i think believe is
correct that the concept of boredom and
the word for
boredom arose in the 18th century when
we first began to
feel that we really had control of
everything and that the whole
of life and the world around us was
under human uh control we could have it
the way we wanted it
and it was then that people started to
feel the sense of emptiness of
as you say the beginnings of nihilism
um and so on so i do think it's very
interesting and in in the book that i
i've said an awful lot more about all
this in the in the book i'm
i've just written called the matter with
things um
and the last part of the book i look at
the
building blocks of the cosmos i mean a
daring thing or perhaps a stupid thing
for somebody
to do unless they they think they
they somehow have an insight into into
physics which i i
i i rely very much on colleagues and on
guidance from physicists but to talk
about time and space
and i think these things are very very
important and one of the things that
people
believe in the real world a lot of
people who have a spiritual take think
really time is an illusion really time
is just a mistake
it doesn't really exist but
i with lee smolin who i
very much admire um who's
gonna be interviewing lee oh
well for what he's worth i i'm an
acolyte i think he's
he's very very interesting and i quote
him a lot in in my new book
but with him i think i'm right in saying
i consider that you know time is
absolutely
primary ontologically speaking
and there is a saying of dogen
chinese sage that even god cannot
er exist without time
now you can i mean that would be a
fascinating conversation all on its own
but there is such a thing as time moving
and developing
and at the same time not running away
an image i quite like is the idea of
being in a stream
and if you move with the stream you
don't stop the stream moving
but as far as you are concerned the
world is permanently there with you
because you are moving with that stream
it's only if you're standing on the bank
impatiently with a clipboard and a
stopwatch watching things pass
and from outside that time appears to
have this erosive quality
um instead it's part of the experience
of becoming
which is what it is to be a human
becoming
speaking of streams and time
is river this is mentioned quite a bit
in your book and i have a
speculative question here
it's okay i'm just going to read it
because i don't have it in my working
memory
so the right brain is the type that when
i say right brain i mean hemisphere so
the right hemisphere is the type that
would come up with the statement that
there's unceasing change
it's constantly constantly changing and
then the left is the one that needs to
stand back and abstract
and see some constancy and then it made
me think about time and then the arrow
of physics
and i'm wondering if you had any
thoughts on the nature of time or the
nature of era of time and physics
well i do curt but i i don't know how
how good they are but i i've thought
about it an enormous amount
and physicists themselves are divided on
the arrow of time
but i tend to be with those who say that
without the arrow of time
nothing could mean or be anything at all
that all
that we know of physics even down to the
you know the most rarefied kind of
contemporary physique
none of it could be without the
existence of time
there could be no processes in fact
without time and i believe that this
processes are prior to things
which is partly why i entitled this book
the matter with things
it's a pun on various levels because i
think there's a problem with our
material
obsession and there's a problem with our
thinking the world is made up of things
so i think you know i don't take the
block
theory of time you know that it's really
a static thing but we just
move about it nor do i take the view
that
um it's it's it's something that
most of the philosophers who've tried to
approach time
with the single exception of bergson
seem to me to have
confused what they're talking about and
unfortunately most people nowadays don't
read bergson
and the reason they don't read bergson
is they've inherited a prejudice
that somehow bergson was wrong
because he had a debate with einstein in
which it said he didn't understand
einstein
but which is equally true that einstein
didn't understand bergson
they were looking at two different
things and they weren't necessarily at
odds with one another
einstein was looking at a kind of time
like a clock time
whereas bergson was looking at time
as not something that can be measured in
that way and
the distinction between a flow
and a series is absolutely fundamental
and bergson spent most of his life
trying to help people see why this was
so fundamental and when i saw it it was
absolutely one of the three or four
great eureka moments of my life
i saw that a lot of the problems that we
have philosophically speaking and with
our attitude to the world
come from us having seen a seamless
motion
as a concatenation of an infinite number
of slices
that sounds like an almost technical
difference but in fact
it goes right to the core of
the two versions of the world that come
into being because the left hemisphere
is always trying to stop time it's
always trying to freeze time
because imagine its idea is to pick
something up or to catch something
so it it wants to freeze it and catch it
and get
it and have it and hold it but you know
as goethe said as blake said when you
try to freeze
the fleeing moment then you're lost
because all is in this process
of change and flow and it's respecting
that
and attuning yourself with it that is
wise not
trying to resist it or pretend it
doesn't exist
so those are some of my thoughts about
time
what is the other model then so i know
you can't go through berkson's entire
model
and i'm assuming you're talking about
bergson as in henry berkson
absolutely yes yes okay okay yes
all i know about henry berkson is that
he's associated with bohmian mechanics
and i need to
investigate more about bergson's
theories i've been told to
so that's on my list for those who are
listening and are eager
i'm working on it what's the alternative
to viewing
time as in infinite slices infinitesimal
slices
well what he noticed and it's very
important
is that it only can be turned into
slices retrospectively
and it's like a point on a line when you
draw a line you don't draw
a point infinitely small and then
another one and so on you the line is
there
in retrospect you can find a point at
which your pencil was at
point a in the line you can
you could designate it but actually
there wasn't
a business of going from point a to
point b or whatever
similarly if you move your arm it is a
single seamless motion
and you can't say i move it to a to b to
c to d
you don't but in retrospect the
representation
of motion can be dissected
but motion itself can't be dissected
similarly the representation
of time can be dissected but time itself
can't be dissected now why that is so
important to me is that one of the most
fundamental differences between the
right hemisphere and the left
is that the left hemisphere deals with
representations
so the right hemisphere deals with
things as they are present
more so it it deals with them as they
presence as heidiger would have said
has they at the very moment that they
are not just present because that sounds
rather passive and mechanical
but as their presence they come into
being for you they come into your
your field of of of being an awareness
and the right the renee chemistry is
therefore with that living moment but
the left hemisphere
is categorizing things you can only
categorize them
a small time after you experience them
so
if you like its world is a world of
a schema a representation a map
which can only be made to make any sense
when there's something that can be
schematized when there's something that
can be
mapped so the difference between what is
in the present moment and what is
reflected on later
and dissected is profound
and what he noticed was that in our
thinking process because we stop
and talk and reflect on things we think
that we find the world as our left
hemisphere
intellect presents it as
a thing that's divided up into areas and
so on whereas
actually the experience of it is not
like that and because we're so
used to
to seeing it the left hemisphere way
most people wouldn't see what i'm
talking about they just about i don't
know what he means by that i mean
how and it's almost like having to
see a spiritual insight or or sort of
you know it's almost like something one
would get from meditation to be able to
see
this difference between and once you see
it it's it's obvious it's everywhere
that the world is this seamless flow and
it's quite different from a dead
concatenation of
of tiny elements
you point out beautifully at one point
that language is like money
and i believe it's because it only takes
its value at the terminus
but you have to cash it in so for
example with cash
it's meaningless until you buy something
with it and then this
place in which it bottoms out is the
body in some sense okay
can you explain what that what you mean
by that
well again what i mean is that um
we can be led into thinking that the
world is the world
that we describe the world is the world
as we reflect on it and
verbalize it but
because that's the bit that we're used
to attending to in fact the right
hemisphere can't speak for the vision
that it sees
so it has to somehow convey to the left
hemisphere
how to use language to convey things
that are not
structured serially and analytically in
the way that the left hemisphere prefers
this is why as i mentioned earlier bohr
said you can only talk about
physics you can only talk about the
sacred
by using poetry and the whole point
about poetry is that it allows one to
see beyond the everyday meanings of
words to
a web of interconnected meanings that
are hinted at
so in a good poem a phrase has
resonances that may set
seven or eight different things going in
your mind rather than
the clinical and illusory
uh antiseptic nature of
the words taken out of context and put
into a kind of
manual of instruction so
words arise out of our bodies they arise
historically
out of emotional responses
animals in their own way have a kind of
very primitive language
they make sounds that mean things and
they express
themselves in gesture and in words
and there's a very long-standing
tradition
um coming forth into the 20th century
that language evolved out of
the generation of embodied meaning in
sound
in other words out of music and this is
where although i very much admire
stephen pinker in many ways i do
rather take issue with his notion that
music is sort of about as useful as
pornography or cheesecake
music is terrifically profound
and is um is actually
more profound than language which is why
we often say well it's beyond me to
express and
and so forth but it's not just the very
rarified things that are beyond language
the philosopher brian mcgee makes a very
good point
that from the the most exalted things to
the most humble things
so he says for example the the towel
that i've dropped on the bathroom floor
there is no language to describe the
shades of color in it
the configuration of the folds the way
in which it relates to everything else
in the room
and yet my consciousness immediately
takes all that in
i'm aware of it i know it but there's no
way i can do it in language
and how can i say leonardo's supper you
know how
how do you so language we we we fool
ourselves when we think that language
is where we live language is something
we use to try and communicate a certain
level
of meaning about the world but not all
of its meaning
so what if someone says we can using
language or some language
give a representation a fairly accurate
one of the last supper
by taking a picture of it and then the
zeros and ones that are the rgb values
you're not able to read and consciously
comprehend it as a
human being but in some way shape or
form it's information
what if someone says that well they've
just
definitely sidestepped the problem by
saying if we take all these
um ones and zeroes which if you look at
them and i look at them
there's no last supper there we can put
them into a machine which creates a
simulacrum we've developed a machine
with instructions on make this come to
be
something like the last supper so that's
really
that's just a way of circumventing the
point which it has not been expressed in
words
it i mean there are certain things you
can try to express in words but you you
immediately come down to a handful of
cliched terms
as nietzsche says language makes the
uncommon
common you know because there's only so
many words you can use to describe
someone's appearance you know they're
tall or short or thin or fat or black or
white or whatever they are
and they have this colored hair and that
colored eyes and
so on but that doesn't get you any
nearer to what your
your loved one looks like you know so uh
language is a a very useful tool but
that's all it is
and it it comes about we learn language
and i know you're going to be talking to
chomsky
and you may have noticed that i gently
disagree
with the i dare to gently decrease but
i'm
encouraged by the fact lots of other
people do too with the idea that
it is something like um
an abstract system in in the brain like
it could be in a computer
waiting for stuff to be filled in
because in fact we develop language
through the process of interrelationship
with other people in an embodied way
which involves emotion and
feeling and gesture and so on this is
how children learn
words um and
so language has its roots in emotion and
the body
it's not some abstract clinical thing
that then gets
clothed in emotion in the body it starts
from those places that's my point
metaphor
is language is cure for the ills
entailed to abide language
explain that that's another one that's
just beautiful
that's a quote okay well it's a
beautiful question
well it tries to compress the idea
that what are the ills i'm referring to
well the ills are
as i say that something that is only a
symbol
or representation of something has to
the thing that it represents
and in this way it's like money that
money can
mean ultimately that i can
have lunch tomorrow with a friend or i
can you know buy a car or whatever it is
but the the
money itself only has that quality when
it's cashed back into life which is very
complex thing
and language is rather like this we can
refer to things
but the experience that we refer to is
no longer in
the representation or the reference it's
it's implied by it that it isn't
actually
there but that doesn't matter because
we think metaphorically all the time and
all language is metaphorical
interestingly the language of science
and philosophy is particularly heavily
dependent on for on
metaphor a point made by lakov and
johnson in their
wonderful books metaphors we live by and
the philosophy in the flesh
so um metaphor
literally means a carrying a cross
and so if you imagine there is this sort
of
divide or gulf between
what the word love means and the
experience of love
metaphors can carry us across that
linguistic divide
they can take us back to the experience
of love
and so something as metaphorical as a
shakespeare play or at a piece of music
or whatever
and music is metaphorical it uses
metaphors based
on bodily movements so risings and
fallings and
resonances and all those things that are
experienced
in a bodily sense so these things are
evoked
in great art in ritual in religion and
in narratives in mythology and and so
forth
and they take us back across the divide
from those sterile words
to the thing that those words were
trying but not
able to evoke
speaking of lakov and johnson you
mentioned
well it's in your book a couple quotes
from them one is that
reason doesn't separate us from the
animals but instead puts us on a
continuum with it
because we're well reason is predicated
in embodiment
now i'm wondering if you can explain
that because
reason to me has to do with logical
inference and so on like if then
statements
how is an if then statement related to
my body per se
well i think the problem might be in
thinking too literalistically about what
your body
is um
i mean it might not be as it were in
your thumb i agree
but your body is everything that is you
apart from well not apart from anything
really i mean
we are for the time that we are alive
on this earth
what our bodies make us
and animals that don't have language
and don't apparently have
any kind of schema of logic can solve
logical puzzles they can reason things
you know crows and magpies
can give correct answers to logical
problems as an eight or nine year old
human being won't
i mean that's just one example but i
mean the more one
reads about animals and even insects the
more one
realizes that the concept that only we
can act
reasonably or rationally is wrong
you've probably seen on youtube there is
in fact
a filmed episode of a crow solving an
eight-step logical puzzle
and although it has solved each step of
the puzzle
in isolation before it has never solved
this particular sequence
and in a matter of about three minutes
or five minutes it's not a very long
clip it has actually taken the eight
steps that will allow it to secure the
food that it's after
now i mean that's in itself what do you
say about that
you know is it the crow's language is
its mathematics or what
somehow from experience and our bodies
are the repositories of
all our experience that is that is
solving this problem
and we don't solve half as many things
as we think by thinking about them
in fact nine tenths of all the great
decisions we make
are done unconsciously we arrive at them
unconsciously
after thinking about other things
sleeping and then saying i think i'll do
that
and when we are not aware of things as
julian james first
did out to me anyway in his 1976 book
um the origins of consciousness in the
breakdown of the bicameral mind
we don't really need consciousness for
very much we can weigh
options form judgments solve puzzles
evaluate beauty fall in love um
and do many many things without thinking
about them
at some level we are working on them
but that what the left hemisphere
privileges as
thinking is just the left hemispheres
kind of thinking
which is explicit in language
and foregrounding whatever is in the
mind but there's a whole
what we're conscious of is only one
percent
maximum of all that there is that's
going on in our minds
so the idea that you know we have to be
conscious and
reason in order to think cleverly is
wrong i mean my one of my favorite
philosophers is a.n whitehead and um
in the book in fact on the structure of
mathematics he's
that um i can't remember the exact
phrase which is wonderful but he says
that
um conscious thought is like
cavalry charges in battle it's expensive
it's wasteful it requires fresh horses
and can only be done at unusual moments
so most of the time we're we're living
perfectly rationally perfectly
intelligently
but without actually thinking about
things explicitly
if we had different bodies or if we grew
up on a different planet a different
evolutionary
chain or tree would we have reason
differently would we reason differently
would our inferences be different
or is logic universal
well how would i know i mean the too
many counterfactuals in that um
[Music]
you can't extrapolate from us to a being
that we can only imagine
and we don't know everything in fact we
can only know what it is
how about let me rephrase it is logic or
the way that we formulated logic and
rationality and reason which i'm
conflating and i know there's a
difference between them
but for the sake of this are they
substrate dependent
so the fact that we are human we came up
with reason in this particular manner
and that aliens might not share our
reason they would come up with different
inferences and it would be valid
well i would i mean again i don't think
anyone can be
certain about such things but my
intuition would be
that reason
and logic are if you like
substrate independent that they're not
just a human
invention but then i think that about a
lot of things that are not so much
inventions as discoveries uh
i mean confusingly the word invention
originally meant
to find something but it now i mean to
make it up
and and so what i think
we do in experience is come to an
awareness and an understanding of things
that are not entirely dependent on us
let me put it that way
and i think these things include um
essential values like good goodness
and evil and beauty and
things like that so and and this is not
unusual
um derek perfect who is a colleague
at all souls and i say a colleague i
mean
in that we were both fellows of the same
college but i mean he was a very great
philosopher and an
atheist but he believed that goodness
and beauty were
ontological primaries that they weren't
things that were just
valuations we put on things because we
happen to like them or not like them
and i would be i would be rather
inclined to that position too
you also talked about okay so
inventiveness is
the etymology of it is related to
finding and then also
being originated so being original has
to do with the origin
going back can you explain that because
that was one part of your book and your
book is quite
lengthy and i wanted to finish this in
time i spent the past
week or so just absorbing pretty much
pure ian
pure ian for this and i made notes
i made notes where i wasn't able to
comprehend fully and i just had to move
on
and that was one of them so do you mind
expounding on original
thinking or coming up with some original
object and its relationship we think of
it as a new
but you also made an analogy that it's
original that is it's going back
yes okay um again i can't remember
exactly what what it was i said that
you're referring to but i think i can
see
what's being hinted at um
it's partly a distinction if i may say
that is in similar structure to that
between
fantasy and imagination so
fantasy is the putting together in a
novel way
of things that elements that really we
have experienced and
are aware of but we put them together
rather as i say like those children's
books
where the pages are divided uh in into
three parts and you can turn the pages
and create animals with a
head of a seal and a body of a goat and
all that sort of thing
um so that is fantasy but imagination is
looking at something
that you think you know and it seems
entirely ordinary
and suddenly seeing it for the first
time this is something wordsworth wrote
about a great deal that it wasn't about
striving for something
um outside of the ordinary
it was finding the extraordinary within
the ordinary
now when when you talk about the origin
or
original thinking many great
revolutionaries and and i don't mean to
say political revolutionaries especially
i mean people who
brought about paradigm shifts in our
thinking
did so by going back to perception that
had been lost sight of
sometimes a thousand years ago or more
and they renovated something that had
been lost from the culture
and that was what was revolutionary
about it
so that i don't think that
an original thinker was somebody who
just makes it all up
because none of us do that we are all
the repositories of centuries millennia
of other people's experience that has
gone into the making of us
and into the ideas that we believe and
so
to strive to be original is to cut
yourself off from that
and to cut yourself off from the rest of
humanity saying look i did this
on my own whereas i think that is a you
know
a typical problem of our age that it's
great that we're individuals don't get
me wrong and i think that
you know conformism is a problem but
we are only also individuals because we
also belong together in a society that
both brings together
and nourishes individual flourishing
curiously the coming together helps the
being different
i i sometimes talk about a couple in a
relationship
that a good couple is one who become
more themselves through the relationship
not less though but it sacrificed their
individuality but it is actually
realized
and enriched and fought in
greater being by the the relationship
going back to where we started
that relationships create the things
that are related as much as the other
way around okay here's what occurs to me
when you say that so let's say you have
a great couple let's say you are you
married
uh i was but i'm not okay so i'm married
so let's just take me as an example
yeah let's say me and my wife i find
that the longer i spend with her
the more i do feel authentic but at the
same time and the more she feels
authentic but at the same time i can
imagine we're becoming closer
and more and more akin to one another's
personality so then i wonder
is the most authentic self for each
individual as we come closer and closer
to our core
is it the same or extremely similar
because otherwise i can't make sense of
this paradox of you becoming authentic
as an individual
but at the same time becoming closer to
other people
well i think that the deep structure of
reality is entirely
paradoxical to the left hemisphere's
take on it that things that are opposite
are absolutely bound up with one another
and it's the left hemisphere that wants
things to be either the one thing or the
other either to be separate or to be
together
but the right hemisphere sees it it
doesn't have to be either or
it has to be both and and what's more
it has to be both either or and
both and i don't know if you've heard of
para consistent logic with grand priest
i have yes yes and i'm not sure i
entirely understand it but what i know
of it i rather like
yeah okay so explain to me to the
audience
how can something be and not be
um well that's a big question
but when we say something is something
we may well mean when viewed in this way
or in this context change the context
change the point of view
and they're equally something different
so
the trouble with the left hemisphere is
that it decontextualizes
this is very very important difference
the right hemisphere alone
understands that what a thing is is what
it is only because of the context in
which it is
and that context doesn't take away from
its being what it is but contributes it
to its being what it is
if you take the context away you
diminish it now that's just a very
obvious down-to-earth example of what
i'm really saying
that we we form social context
we form loving contexts and in those
contexts we are changed we are altered
everything we do everything we think
alters us
which is why we need to be careful about
how we think as i say attention is a
moral act
it changes us and it changes the world
well that's one of the most frightening
aspects of your book
okay you know we can get to that part
later a distinction that's important for
the audience
it was important and enlightening for me
was between
vissen and kennen i believe they're
german words about knowledge yes do you
mind expanding
yes or if you prefer and
connect in french and the simple way of
saying it is that
is knowing that something is the case
whereas
connector cannon is knowing something
direct so i know that
paris is the capital of france i know
paris
because of the times i've spent there
and what they've meant to me
you know i know that um
you know the the the tree in my garden
is of a certain species and a certain
um height and so forth but i only know
it
because i walk past it
stop under it and experience it so
really
there's a distinction between a kind of
abstracted
form of knowing data knowing things
about things and the knowing of them
rather than about them
i'll tell you one of the aspects of your
book that i found unsettling let's say
i i've had this experience i think i've
talked about it before on another
podcast
perhaps at the bernardo castro if you've
heard of him
where it was the middle of the night i
had woken up from a dream
and then as i was falling back to sleep
in this
hypnagogic state i heard
my wife say a word i don't know what
she's i don't know
i don't i still don't know she said it
or didn't say but it could have been it
doesn't actually matter it was like yes
or okay
and then i wasn't sure if she had
actually said it
and i started to go into a spiral
of extreme anxiety and i'm not a person
who's ever had a panic attack in my life
but then i started to feel like am i
going crazy
am i am i hearing voices i don't want to
hear voices
oh my gosh and then i started to think
okay don't hear a voice don't hear voice
but then i was thinking about freudian
repression am i now repressing a voice
that will come back even harder later
oh no so should i move toward a voice
what would what if the voice tells me to
kill myself i'm not suicidal i don't
hate my
life not in the least what if it tells
me to harm someone else
and and then i i had to wake my wife up
and tell her
please help me because i'm i'm i need
help breathing
and then so she calmed me through that
the next day i had a similar panic
attack
and then two days later had half of one
then it just went away i even talked to
my doctor about this she said you should
go to psychotherapy to talk
talk this out but it it ameliorated on
its own
then a couple days ago this is fresh but
this came from your book this is why i
i love you but then i curse you at the
same time there's plenty of talk in your
book about schizophrenia
and each time that would come up my
heart would race and i'm hearing myself
in it where i'm not the type of person
that as you know if i'm talking to you
i'm not a a fundamentalist materialist
who dispenses with the divine and so on
in fact i'm extremely open to it
and the eulogisms i get for this channel
is that i'm extremely
open and actually trying to understand
like i'm trying to understand your point
of view i'm trying to
morph it with mine i'm trying to
understand other people's but that's
extremely
difficult because it puts me on such
unstable ground
that i don't know what's real and then
i'm constantly questioning what's real
is this real am i the only one that's
real my fake
is are people lying to me and and
sometimes just when i say it out loud it
it helps me through it part of it is
like i'm keeping it in and i don't want
to scare my spouse i don't want to scare
someone else
but i also thought another part is that
there's no one else that i hear talk
about this much not no one in the public
sphere
and so i thought one time i heard
peterson was schizophrenic it was turns
out to be false
but that actually gave me gave me hope
because i was like oh my gosh someone
else is experiencing this
and then i thought okay kurt why don't
you talk about it first of all it's
curative to myself
second of all someone else might hear it
and be like okay this is
i'm not someone who's asinine and and so
maybe someone else who's somewhat normal
is going through this castrop said kurt
don't worry
this is part of the spiritual journey
when you question consciousness and you
involve yourself in these subjects this
will happen
but either way what you said which is
that you view the world more and more
mechanistically that's the left brain
now that's my entire life up until maybe
a few years ago
because i'm trained as a physicist a
scientist
and that and that you're extremely
speaking to yourself over and over and
over and i feel like that's what i do
and i've estrude music too
for the past 12 years i haven't listened
to music because i just find it to be a
time waster
and i'm wondering how much have i hurt
myself by doing so
i wanted to say this to you because well
first i just want to hear your thoughts
and then you can also relate it to the
world at large yes
well um i think it's not unusual for
people to
to have these experiences and
people who think a lot ponder a lot
philosophize a lot conceptualize a lot
do come to this crisis of doubt if you
like and it's
i mean the first great exponent of this
was descartes
um but
for his age he lived a remarkably
ungrounded kind of existence what i mean
is that most people then still
lived a more rooted embodied existence
and he probably
by his personality as much as anything
was inclined
to i think he had a schizoid temperament
actually
and why this is important is that
there's a wonderful book which i
often mentioned and then we'll mention
again
by louis sass a psychologist at rutgers
called
madness and modernism and it is a
fascinating
work and
it was completely another of these sort
of eureka moments for me when i read it
because he drew so many parallels
between schizophrenia
and modern culture
i mean even including high culture and
he drew
25 or 30 parallels that are clear to
anyone
like him or me who has treated many
patients with schizophrenia
between the way they encounter things
experience them and aspects of modernity
and this comes together for me in the
fact that the left hemisphere is in a
way ungrounded
it has taken things taken them out of
context
taking them out of the lived experience
of the body
just detached them from what they mean
to us
and then said i don't know what this
means because
as it were having taken it out ripped it
out of the context it would give it
meaning
it no longer has any meaning this
induces a sort of what's real what isn't
real
now only people who live the sort of
very strange life that we do
are likely to be tormented by this
because they don't see consciousness
there's something in here
and a reality that's just out there we
come back to something
we talked about a little earlier and
could talk about a lot more
which is how are you see two things
related co-creating it's neither that
there's just an in here and an out there
nor that it's all made up or it's you
know
so it's a it's a connection
we are beings that can
attend to the world that is our essence
and as louis lavelle of 20th century
philosopher said attention is love love
is a pure attention to the existence of
whatever
is other another person another thing
and i think that that
is how we relate to the world that it is
not
it's not alien to us at all nor are we
alien to it it's not that we have to
figure it out as if it were an odd thing
that had dropped in our past you know um
paley
in his um deism thought that
it gave the image that the universe was
like a watch that some
sorry paley an 18th century bishop
yes yes thomas paley i think he was um
said that
um you know imagine the world it's like
a
a watch you walk on a heath you find
this watch
you immediately know there must be a
watchmaker i mean this thing didn't just
happen
so he says the world is like this and
dawkins
says and i think very fairly that he is
himself
a paleous without god because he just
like paley thinks there is a mechanism
here that is working itself out
he just doesn't think it's god he thinks
it's genetics that there is something as
it were
in a gene the robot that
controls et cetera these images of
control
are there in him as they would be in the
idea of a deistic god
i what i mean by a deity god is a an
engineering god
an engineer who is separate from
creation winds it up and
occasionally tinkers with it whereas i
believe whatever is divine is in the
fabric
of the world and is not known not
certainly even to whatever that divinity
is
it's a process of true creation sort of
exhilaration of that that carries the
whole process of creation of a creative
cosmos
anyway i'm i'm probably not making sense
it's so hard to convey these things
briefly but
shelling in the 18th century was one of
my favorite um
philosophers was able to express this
not not very easy german i have to agree
but this is at the core of his
perception that
the inner and the outer as is often said
in
many non-western cultures they are
distinct but they're not separate
and that's a very important point that
it comes back again to the business of
not being lost
in a context you're distinct
from another person but you're not
separate from them or sort of divided
from them
you're connected to them but you're
still distinct
and i sort of think of the world as
being seamless but with
you can go seamlessly from
um red to green without even knowing
that this has happened
you know in a three or four minute film
the color can change nobody notices the
color changing but it's changed
completely
so it's possible to move along a
continuum and
and the spectrum of colors is an example
of something that is not a concatenation
it's not lots of little separate colors
it is simply a spectrum
that can be moved along in such a way
that you can go from something very
distinct to something else distinct but
they're never been separate they've
never been
cut off from one another they they're
part of the same
whole and i think that a number of
physicists that i've
read in my attempts to understand modern
um well quantum field theory actually is
the theory that
i find most congenial to my philosophy
and seems to be being espoused by a lot
of
physicists but in that case again
things can be distinct but not
ultimately separate they they
belong to fields which can be more
concentrated or collapsed in certain
ways at certain times in certain places
actually speaking of quantum field
theory on these
pages that i have notes for you at the
back because i thought that we were
scheduled for two hours earlier by
accident so i was
just doing some quantum field problems
just to get myself more familiar with it
because i
i've been out of the game for a little
while okay
why is it that you mentioned one day
you'll be able to explain it to me
why why is it that non-rhythmic music is
salutary compared to rhythmic music
see let me explain my reasoning for this
well first of all you mentioned it in
the book
but second i told you i don't listen to
music i don't get pleasure for music
and i i
i haven't done so for maybe 12 or even
14 years i play music like i can play
this and sing
i like to do that i like to listen to
eminem occasionally
but i don't like to listen to music and
for me it's because i'm so in my head
i'm such a child of the enlightenment
let's say that
i see that as a waste of time and i just
need to be thinking
and it came from when i was around 18
and i was
on a train and the train ride passed in
like two minutes when it was a 20-minute
train ride and it was because i was
listening to music and i stopped and
thought
that's not good because i could have
been thinking could have been solving
problems
so then i'm like from this day forward
on the train you just think
think think think think it reminds me of
the
first angel then he spoke to himself and
i feel like i have inadvertently been
harming myself and now what i'm doing is
a slow process of undoing
and your book is helping but it's also
unnerving thank you either way you said
that
okay listen music these days is rhythmic
and that's not the best embodiment
non-rhythmic music is
so can you explain i don't i don't think
i said that
i i really don't um i haven't got
anything against
rhythmic music i just said that the most
powerful
expressive elements in music include
melody and harmony and that rhythm is
only
a part of music and it's the only part
that the left hemisphere really
understands
especially very basic pounding beats
that are repetitive and
mechanical um because even complex beats
with cross rhythms and syncopations are
better understood by the right
atmosphere
but melody and armor are really very
much dependent
for most people non-professional
musicians dependent on
the right hemisphere and all i was
really saying
is that in our culture i was just
pointing to the
101 ways in which we can see
what i consider to be the the dire
impact of
not using or paying attention to what
our right hemispheres will still tell us
if we just
listen to what they're enabling us to
understand experience and
live in
one of those um one of those 101
things is the way in which music has
changed interestingly to be
largely a matter of rhythm and that
melodies and harmonies are not as
settled as they they used to be
and are in many kinds of music but
there's nothing wrong with rhythm in
itself
although there is something very
important about variation in rhythm
so certainly in playing
if you're a great pianist you you
wouldn't
play something in the way that a
computer would play the notes
with exact same lengths and exact same
intervals
um there's something called rubato which
you may know of which is
the business of very slight variations
from outer bar
in the movement of the music
um and this is a parallel to the fact
that living rhythms are always variable
they're not
uh mechanical and i was absolutely
amazed when i was on the
obstetrics wards um
when i was a doctor in training
and just begun that attachment to learn
that when the fetus the heartbeat the
fetal heartbeat
is entirely rhythmical the baby is an
emergency
the baby is in danger of dying
and a healthy fetus has a variable
heartbeat
now i mean that's an image to me of many
other things
that you know that there is a beauty in
the slight hesitancies
in dance in music it's very
very hard to put your finger on what
they are and they're
they're within an overall frame of
irregularity so the irregularities
within the overarching frame of
regularity
and this comes to something very very
deep for me
which is that
we need togetherness but we also need
distinctness we need individuality but
we need
um the whole but the important thing is
we should be under the embrace of
force for togetherness not the force for
separation
so in brief we need the force for
division
and we need the force for union we need
both
both need to be present we need to be
unified
not divided this reminds me of longing
versus want
in your book you mentioned longing is a
unification a stretching out to
but want is a desire which puts you it
separate from
yes is there a connection or is that
just in my head
no i'm delighted that you made that
connection i think it's it's exactly
right
from from my point of view and in fact
there is um
if people are interested if you if you
google mcgilfrid's longing and one thing
i think it's called
i gave an hour-long talk um in london
about four years ago on the distinction
between longing and wanting
and nowadays it seems to me that we have
lost
the sense of a longing for something to
which we already feel
an attraction and which is calling to us
and which we are
we are sort of uh rather
blind way trying to to reach towards but
constant reaching out to
instead we have once you know i don't
that that
you get to put it in your little bag of
stuff what do you want in a relationship
you even say that
well i think these words all have their
meaning and they all have their value
and they they will
have their place but but no i think
there was a very i mean it's fascinating
the word
long literally comes from an anglo-saxon
rude langion which means to stretch out
something that is gone from you but
which you are still connected you want
to reconnect with
in fact it is this
sisterly and diastole if you like which
are from the heartbeat you know the
sisterly followed by the diastole the
lup followed by the top
there's this kind of contraction and
release is
the way in which movement happens in
nature by
alternations of that kind produce
something that is just a kind of
addition
of the two in some neutral way or a or
perhaps a compromise of 50 50.
it produces something completely new
this is the point
it is the creation the creativity of
your life of this world of the cosmos
depends on our ability to see that
opposites need to be held together
the world is not as simple as we think
it is things that we think are good
also can seem kill something that is bad
the things that we think are bad also
conceal something that is good
and we need to finesse these things in
order to find our way in the world
what i mean by the opposition bringing
something new into being
is the tension of a string of a guitar
or a violin
it's important for that that it's pulled
in two directions at once
in fact if it weren't pulled in two
directions at once it wouldn't
work you might say well that's a waste
of energy why pull things in two
directions at once why not come to an
agreement and a compromise
and just stop pulling well then you
don't have a string anymore you don't
have a violin anymore you don't have any
music anymore
well something comes out of that
conflict which is very important sorry
to be fair in string theory you can't
have closed loop strings and you just
give them attention it's just like a
variable you vary
oh i i really wasn't um uh pretending to
talk about string seriously
you don't understand it i know okay
when you say that you're like we need to
we're separate
but we're also together and this impulse
to be separated
should be there and the impulse to be
together should be there we should
be guided by the together one more so
than the separate one
that's the individuality okay that to me
it reminds me is i i'm not meaning this
by the way can i just say i'm not
meaning this principally or only
uh to do with social relations i'm
thinking of it as
a metaphysical structural feature of
reality that it has this structure
of the need for difference and
togetherness not just we as human beings
have it
okay well now you gave me another idea
so let's say i'm walking along
the beach yeah and i'm looking at the
waves and the sand and the sun
am i supposed to feel or is it good for
me to feel
connected to it and feel as if the waves
are alive in some manner and i'm
speaking to the rocks
because in the dead end left hemispheric
view i see them or one would see them as
impressions picturesque impressions upon
my slate
of sense so sense data pressed upon me
but then i can
and then i know that that's associated
with schizophrenias schizophrenic
ideation in its extreme okay but then in
the other extreme i could see
someone going and talking to the rocks
and and holding them up and kissing them
as that its own form of
psychosis but i'm not sure i don't know
if that's actually associated with
schizophrenic
thought either way i want to hear so
which one should i do should i
stand back passively of you or should i
treat it somehow emulated in my brain as
this is living
be curt be in this world as if you're
living
engaging with it but these are not just
plastic objects that of wood
they're they're also not beings let's
say but they're
there's something to them there's some
life that they have so how
how does one dance that web because i
can see
inane craziness on both ends of the
spectrum
but does it have to be one or the other
in keeping with what i've been saying
isn't it an error to go to one extreme
of either of these not because the
reality exists in a compromise
but because there is a wholly different
position that is only found when you
reconcile the two opposites
that is my point um and it's imaged in
that
taut string um but
i think it's a very unusual view we have
of the world
that we are separate from it and it is
dead
uh and that any life in it is something
we attribute to it
i argue and it's too long an argument to
do now
i even argue that inanimacy
is if you like the ultimate limit case
of animacy
not that animacy is some weird thing
that popped into the cosmos
i think animacy is of the essence
of a conscious universe in different
ways in different degrees
as an animosity or are the union animals
no no as
as as in things being animated so
obviously yes um but
we don't have to to go to to to that
that extr
well not an extreme but but to that
length if you like
um we i wouldn't have time to justify
that position but i think i do in my
book
but in any case most people at most
times in the world
have not failed to make a proper
scientific assessment and
come up with a theory that things around
them are alive
they know they're alive because they
actually experience
that and we have told ourselves that we
can't be experiencing that because
it's just not wrong isn't it i mean an
age of science
but what do we know about that actually
science is not dealing with that
question
science is not able to talk about
whether there is
um something that has consciousness or
animacy
in the world outside of our own
heads so
i don't think that one needs to either
tell oneself one's wrong when one feels
a sense of connectedness
or think that being properly connected
means
you're being being swallowed up and you
don't you know love those waves so much
that you go into a rough scene and get
drowned so
you need to keep keep walking this
balance and it's all about the balance
or harmony harmony was the greek word
and it's a word that we've lost because
i mean our world has so little harmony
in it
things that we call harmony are actually
dictated fiats that things must be like
this but no
true harmony is is a kind of thing that
has to evolve
between things being fully themselves
and not pretending to be something
they're not
so yeah i think it i think it is a very
very
important element i i wrote also an
article
for the journal of consciousness studies
on the question of the self
because i think there's a confusion you
know that
the holy person or the wise person has
no self
and i think i know what is meant i think
i can see very clearly
what has meant not a narrow egotistic
selfish um fragmentary atomistic
self of course but at the same time
by growing in richness and
thinking and meditating and
creating and just being you are
growing a soul you are growing a person
you are growing
fulfilling an individual element of the
cosmos that will never be there again
and surely to say that that's all
valueless and the whole
business of existence is to try and deny
that and get as far away from it as
possible
seems to me a little bit um negative
because even the buddha you know
had to sleep had to eat had to go to the
lavatory and if somebody
shot the buddha he didn't go well he
didn't shoot me
because he did you know every everybody
has
their individual self but there's a very
big difference between what jung
called the self which is a sort of
mature thing that you grow into
and the ego which is this sort of more
left hemispheric
sense of the self as the acquirer the
manipulator
the one that wields power and that's
very important again
in the spiritual philosophies
of most cultures the renouncing of power
because power is very much the left
hemisphere's major tool
it exists in order to make us powerful
to get things to grab
things to get prey to build things to
make things
and thinks that we will become happier
or better in doing so
although all the evidence is very clear
we don't become happier or morally about
a people by doing it
what you say just makes me think of
there's quite a few thoughts i'll
i'll splay out two of them one is okay
freud said
or at least freud surmised that his id
ego and so on would have some
morphological equivalent in the brain
if neuroscience would just progress now
it sounds like what you're saying is
to some degree that's true because the
left hemisphere is associated with the
ego
is that correct
i don't really want to to say yes to
that or no to it because
in some senses yes in some senses no it
it depends too much what you mean by ego
and some aspects of the superego might
be better identified with the frontal
lobes rather than with either right or
left hemisphere
and certainly it wouldn't be right to
say the right hemisphere is the id
the right hemisphere is the morally
self-abnegating
part of us the part that enables us to
be good friends parents and citizens
it is the bit that david hecht at
ucl in london says quite
straightforwardly
and i i think i i'd sign up to it
largely
that the right hemisphere is moral in
its attitudes and the land is basically
immoral it
it is there for what it can get is the
left hemisphere
immoral or amoral immoral
okay in other words it has a morality
and it has it has really no sense of
well let me just
go back on that in the book
this new book i argue that the left
hands can't really understand morality
it hasn't any really a sense of morality
so
it substitutes for morality calculation
it says if i weigh up the consequences
of this act and the consequences of that
act
i can find out which is the morally
right act that sounds very good
but there are many circumstances in life
in which it would be profoundly immoral
even to carry out a calculus of that
kind
and it's in normal circumstances apart
from one or two
philosophers it's mainly people who have
right hemisphere damage or frontal lobe
damage
or are very severely autistic who think
in that way
most of us have a sense that morality is
something more complex than that
and that we don't do it would be quite
wrong to make decisions
based on an entirely dispassionate
mathematical
in fact how would you attach the values
i mean
would a would the value gained by many
sadistic um pedophiles
around the world outweigh
in the pleasure given to thousands of
people the suffering of one
innocent child that is tortured for fun
well
if you have to do a sum on that then you
there's something wrong with your moral
sense
and i know that's an extreme case but
i'm afraid it's a rather important
indicator of something that is wrong
with utilitarianism
on its own utilitarianism has a place
sometimes
but again it's this problem the left
hemisphere thinks that whatever it is it
does is the only thing and the best
thing
whereas it's actually not even core to
morality utilitarianism
i believe in a kind of
um objective moral that i'm so sorry
do you believe in objective morals
well it depends what you mean by
objective i i don't believe it that
they're just subjective in the sense
that they're made up by us but i don't
believe they're
objective in the sense that
that a machine would be able to
calculate it
i mean when i say objective i mean that
there's something at the
structure of reality at the fundamental
the abutment that has
morals and that it's not just absolutely
no no thank you for clarifying no
definitely
no i think the cosmos is moral um which
isn't to say that it's all good
of course because morality includes the
whole spectrum
but i don't think morality is an element
that we've somehow
[Music]
we've come to and it's simply an
expression of things we like and things
we don't like i think it is a very
profound aspect of the business of being
alive
as is the appeal of beauty and of
complexity
of mathematics of of music
of landscape all these things embody
something
that unless we are
you know crippled cribbed and confined
by the left hemispheres
take on things obviously speak to us
about something more important than what
the left hemisphere
alone can tell us there's nothing wrong
you know it's not that we
all be better if we had a left
hemisphere stroke of course not
as i often say it's my second favorite
hemisphere it's terribly important
but it's you know it got to be under the
supervision of the right house it's a
very very good servant it carries out
very useful tasks
but it hasn't got the site to see which
of the useful tasks so
it must be under the aegis the
protection the supervision of
the right hemisphere it's a a bad master
but a very good servant
in christianity there's a heavy heavy
emphasis on both love and truth
and it's not just
speak the truth no matter what it's
speak speak the truth guided by love
so the truth has to serve love i'm
wondering is that
mirrored by the by hemispheric structure
is that one right brain is
the love in this sense and then the left
is the one that's associated with truth
at least objectively can be associated
with some form of objective truth or am
i just going off on a limb
i think you're going you're going an
awful lot further than i would get
i i don't think i would say any of that
um but i think it's perfectly legitimate
to speculate
when you're thinking about the richness
of an idea or an image or a metaphor
about what it can illuminate so i don't
think there's anything wrong with
having an idea and thinking well maybe
not but i think honestly i'd say maybe
not to that one
what do you make of daniel dennett's
explaining consciousness
our consciousness explained
well i i think it's a perfect um
expression a very intelligent expression
of a certain
kind of take on the world a veltan
chaung which
is to use the term that you invoked at
the beginning of our talk
that is i think rather sadly
impoverished
um and it's not a thing that can easily
be solved by
argument these are things that you come
to through experience
in other words they involve kennen as
well as vissen
and they come out of the fruit of many
kinds of attention to the world
not just the claim that comes from
arguing in a seminar room
and so i not there's anything wrong with
doing that but again it's a
supplementary aspect of what philosophy
is
philosophy has got a little bit lost i
think as a sort of technical
department in the university somewhere
somewhat like engineering and
interestingly dan dennett says that if
he hadn't been a philosopher he'd
probably been an engineer
um which which seems to be intuitively
right
um but it also
points to perhaps a certain i don't know
unwillingness to accept that things
might be beyond what he knows and more
complex
it's interesting that engineers for
example have a very high
i did a study on this at the moment the
hospital which i've
never actually got around to publishing
but it was very clear that i didn't
expect the results
that people who became mentally ill
at university
with a major mental illness those who
became manic-depressive
i had an emotional disturbance
as a primary element in their psychosis
were not
principally philosophers or engineers
but those with schizophrenia were
massively more likely to have been
studying engineering
or philosophy than any other subject and
it's also come to light that um
terrorists who are fundamentalists
have engineers are more represented
amongst them than amongst other people
i i you know of course i'm not trying to
say that
that that all engineers are like this
but i'm just pointing to a sort of
certain kind of
i don't know the predilection for
engineer-like thinking
is what is also so it's a pre-election
for
for categorical thinking and for a lack
of willingness to accept that things
are not certain and maybe much more
complex than one
has given them credit for being let's
see
i wanted i'm trying to find this one
question
about well okay before i find that
question
i'm curious how is it that you were able
to pin down the insights about the right
brain
by using your left brain because this is
a book written in language and so on so
did you engage in meditative exercises
did you speak to spiritual gurus
how did you do it or did you just read
dispassionately the literature and then
you said okay this is what the right
brain does let me write that down
well i think it was very like my idea of
the right brain
guiding in the left hemisphere doing
much of the sort of procedural work
so it's often been pointed out to me
that without a highly active left
hemisphere
i couldn't possibly have written that
book with its attention to
expressing extremely difficult things
that are not intuitively
the things that most people nowadays in
the west think in language
and arguing for them and inducing an
enormous amount of scientific evidence
um so i think the left hemisphere
as i say was a valuable servant to me
but what i hope is that i was guided by
a sense of as something that i was
i was aware of but not fully aware of
and wanted to explore more and to bring
into
more into the light really never fully
into the light but a bit further into
the light so that it could be better
seen
i think this is the process it's it's
more like
seeing a gestalt seeing a form then it
is
culminating an argument in which step a
leads to b
through to zed and then you switch off
and say right proved
that's never going to be a success in
philosophy in my view
i say rather controversially because the
world is not like that
and plato right at the start thought
that we shouldn't even write philosophy
down
that it could only be done by people
living people talking to one another for
a long period getting to know one
another
and that then an intuition would come
about
like a spark would be kindled now that's
right at the founding of modern western
philosophy but we've got a very long way
from it
um i i yes i i think the
the image that i i like is and it's
occurred to me
when i was writing my very first book in
my 20s was what i was trying to say
was that we have understandings of
things
specifically works of literature or
of music or art or whatever they are not
by a linear chain of discovery
but by circling them and seeing them
from different aspects
and that it's more like a picture that
gradually comes into focus or even quite
suddenly at some point comes into focus
so at the time you're looking at it it
doesn't seem coherent
but then gradually you see bit comes and
you see i
see you have an aha moment and things
begin to fall into place and then other
things
refuse to fall into the pictures you've
got and they help guide
the next stage so there's a new gesture
a better one
replaces and indeed in philosophy what
we're doing is always just replacing one
gestalt with another
what i mean by a gestalt is a form which
is a whole
which is more than any of the parts i
know you know this but i'm just saying
it in case any
listener doesn't define the term
familiar but it's the whole idea that
there is a whole of something that can't
be accessed fully
by simply dividing it up into its parts
something essential to it is lost
i have a quote here it's you quoting
sauce from schizophrenic mind and i'm
not gonna i'm just gonna paraphrase it
because it's a quite a
long paragraph it says that when you
engage in the world in a passive
disengaged
self-conscious stare at the world in an
objective manner
it becomes bizarre alien frightening and
that's akin to
the schizophrenic mind however yes the
process of mindfulness
mindfulness meditation seems shockingly
similar where you're supposed to stand
back and you simply observe
no judgment don't engage it's all just
being fed to you
yes but yet on the one hand mindfulness
meditation is seen as salutary but then
obviously schizophrenia is not it's
unadaptive
so how do you balance those two or solve
that antinomy
well in terms of hemisphere
the hemisphere paradigm
one is what happens when you allow the
left hemisphere only to be
working this is the standing back so
that your body
is not involved so that your feeling
self is not involved
so that you have deliberately cut off
all the contacts from something
and then see it as something utterly
alien
whereas the mindfulness
is and in interestingly and perhaps not
essentially but
interestingly the science of mindfulness
shows that it does
rely more heavily on right hemisphere um
[Music]
activations than left and indeed on
changes practitioners in the structure
of the right hemisphere
but i don't think that's the important
point i think what is going on
in mindfulness is that you are adopting
the
position of the right hemisphere towards
the world which is in fact
although you might think it is similar
it is the exact opposite
because where as the one is as it were
isolated and detached the other is
standing back
enough to allow the self not to crowd
everything out
where the one is actually thinking about
things all the time the other is saying
no i'm not going to think at all
i'm just going to be there with it
now in the first case in the sort of
frightening alienating way which
interestingly
uh schreiber describes the 19th century
judge who
became schizophrenic in his middle years
and wrote a wonderful
journal of his mental illness um
schreiber describes exactly this that
the world becomes alien as soon as you
start reflecting on it so much that you
you drop all the connection with it
now in mindfulness you are not absent
from the world
it's about being fully present in the
world the
the idea is that in normal life you're
not fully present you're not actually
there with the world at all because your
thoughts your ideas your judgments
yourself is crowding it all out so in
fact they're quite opposite
in their tendency
i sometimes talk about something called
necessary distance
and what i mean by that is exactly that
kind of distance
that enables you to see something
properly as a whole
not to swamp it but it doesn't mean
being so far detached from it that you
can't see it or understand it or relate
to it
that would be the opposite of necessary
distance
that would be toxic distance and there
is such a thing as
toxic fusion in which you can be so
close to something you can't
see it make it out or accept its being
at all
why is it that you associate it in a
metaphor the rising up and floating with
the left hemisphere and then being on
the ground
with the right hemisphere because to me
i would think that the left one is the
one that's on the ground manipulating
and the left
sorry and the right hemisphere is the
one that can see the whole picture
yes well you're very
i think entirely rightly put your finger
on
the way in which any one metaphor
breaks down in these circumstances and
you have to use a whole variety of them
what i was really thinking of was that
it it was like the difference between
someone who is actually
living a life on the ground and somebody
who is
doing a sort of aerial photograph of it
in order to map
it that as where all that is there on
the ground is present to the person
who's experiencing it headlong in the
business of life
who actually sees the garden sees their
children you know hears the wind and
sees the stars and the mind that is
already dissecting analyzing and
remote so you're quite right that the
left hemisphere this is another way of
putting the finger on what i was trying
to say
is there's a kind of distancing which
can be removed but there's a kind of
distancing which enables you to see the
whole picture
just as the kind of being fixed on the
here and now
which is generous and wise and allows
you to understand it
and are being fixed on the here and now
which is just about
acquisition and accumulation of power
and influence
so they each contribute to both as you
would expect
each has a version of closeness each has
a version of distance
as i keep saying every concept you care
to name
has a left hemisphere take and a right
hemisphere take so it's not
as i say that they do different things
they do the same things but they do them
always from a coherently
different perspective i see coherently
different
because i can imagine that they don't
completely differ
yes what i'm trying to suggest is
within themselves coherent i see what i
mean like a self-consistent
yes yeah self-consistency so that for
example
you might say so how does the left
hemisphere view language how does the
right hemisphere blue language
how does the left hemisphere view
distance how does the right hemisphere
distance okay
they don't sound like they've got very
much in common but when you come
to look at how each of them
looks at everything there are very
common threads that are consistent
through how the right hemisphere deals
with every aspect of existence
and very common threads that
characterize the way the left hemisphere
does
so they're not coherent together so much
as coherent
within themselves but the art of life
is bringing these two things to bear in
such a way that the richness that
they can only really come from them both
is not swamped by the left hemisphere
trying to take over the whole show
it doesn't happen the other way around
because the right hand people often say
well you
you've put your finger on you know what
a left hemisphere world looks like
because at the end of the book in the
last chapter i sort of describe a world
in which the left hemisphere
based on what the reader knows about it
would
make of a world and in reading it you i
think
most people see a very clear portrait of
what is happening to us now
so people say but what would a right
hemisphere world look like
the answer is well it would be a very
balanced one and there's never been a
civilization that
didn't have its left hemisphere aspects
because the right hemisphere sees more
it therefore knows that it needs the
left hemisphere
it after all if it's if it's the master
it appointed the embassy because it
realized it needed the emissary
the emissary coming into existence and
being crowned as this
you know a very wise minister
thinks it knows everything when it
doesn't and that's the problem
it's people who think they've got it all
in the bag
now is our consciousness i think sorry
sorry i was wondering is our
consciousness
residing in the left brain or residing
in the right hemisphere or is it in the
interplay between both or is it being
fed from both
because as i hear you say the left
thinks it's in charge it reminds me of
our consciousness that thinks
we're the ones that are in control and
then it has and then we have to be
confronted with
a myriad of psychological studies to
show no you're a monkey on a elephant's
back and you think that you're
controlling it but this elephant's gonna
go wherever it wants so are we
when i'm speaking with you right now or
when one is speaking with you are we
either
engaging in one of those modes are we
primarily on the left are we
both somehow being fed from each
when you start talking about the
relationship between consciousness and
the brain then you know you really
are in very very rarefied areas and i
don't shy from talking about it in the
book a chapter which is
the length of a short book on its own on
it
but i think that
you see that let's let's start with the
monkey on the elephant
in my experience the elephant
is all that we are not currently aware
of
and the monkey is just that foolish
little bit that is doing
the thinking and talking consciously now
so
earlier i said most of everything we are
doing
is not stuff we're doing consciously in
fact if we try to do it consciously we
do it very badly
it's one of the interesting things is
that the better you get as a chess
player
the less you think consciously about it
right
so the same is true of a surgeon or a
pilot
they have to think a lot to begin with
but as they get better they think less
and less
so the the role of that monkey is
rightly considered not
important compared with the elephant
which is wise and has memory
so that's the way i'd look at that i
don't see those
images as therefore telling us that
we're just the puppets or play things
of something else i mean that's a very
very skewed left hemisphere way of
thinking about it
of course it's only interested in power
and control but actually what it is it's
saying no
what you are is rooted very deeply in
the whole of your experience including
the bits that you're now conscious of
but including many that you work on
yourself for
another mint and now and things that you
perhaps never conscious of so anyway
um and complicatedly consciousness has
two meanings one is
as against the things you're not aware
of like
oh um at that moment i i wasn't
conscious of the fact that it's
you know my friend's birthday or
something like that
but it also is used in the sense of what
you lose when you go into a coma or die
so
what i'm really saying is there is a
kind of consciousness that we
find all too obvious and over value
which is the one that does the chatting
and talking and thinking
right now but what i mean by our
conscious awareness of the world is a
deep thing that is going on in both
hemispheres all the time
when we narrow down to the conscious
mind we're talking about that
focus of the left hemisphere an image i
sometimes use again if it's helpful
is that we sometimes think of the
unconscious as underneath the conscious
as like a sort of
a deep tank that you would come to if
you went through the floor of your
conscious
the conscious tank but instead i would i
would think of it as
a stage that is basically in darkness
except where the floodlight the
spotlight happens to go
and when that moves to a certain place
something suddenly shows up
but when it moves away that something
doesn't go away it's just that at the
moment you're not looking at it you're
looking at something else
so we are a field of consciousness
in fact liechtenberg says and shelling
says
it thinks in me so as it were there is a
field of me
which is the minus of me and all that
goes into that
and it's not something alien from me it
is who i am
and it's out of that that my thinking
comes the
cartesian idea that there must be a
little chatty ego
for there to be an eye helps us
forget or miss the two depths of our
being so anyway
when you when you do split brain
experiments um
you can interrogate each hemisphere as a
time and each one is conscious
it's just that the right hemisphere
can't in that moment though
those things sorry sorry sorry to
interrupt
because i'm super curious about this
okay so you have a good one
sodomy and then you ask the question
and then you confabulate an answer
because you don't know what or at least
the part of the agreement okay
but that's the part of you that is
conscious and it seems like the
consciousness is still in the left and
the right is in control but it's
unconsciously in control doing a process
so is that another way of thinking about
it or can you attribute consciousness to
the right hemisphere well i think
consciousness is
um it's not a thing it is of course a
process
and indeed the brain itself is not a
thing but a process
i mean every cell of your body is a
process
it's much more like a process than a
thing it looks like a thing because in
photograph it will do a diagram of it
but actually that thing that looks like
a cell membrane is actually very fluid
and it's
changing its position and its
composition all the time
so even a single cell is actually
a sea of things that are changing and
moving and interconnect
now the brain is like that on a
infinitely larger scale
i have a feeling that your new book this
is pretty much what it's talking about
is that there are no things
they're only processes is that correct
even yes it's not that i think there's
anything wrong with conceiving of things
as things i mean
for example this laptop on my lap is
perfectly properly described as a thing
in a certain way it's just a way in
which we encounter the world for certain
purposes a very good one
it's just that on the whole it's a
mistake to think that the world is
structured out of things anyway
um when it comes to
the consciousness and the brain i mean i
think of consciousness
as being sequestered for a while
in a kind of area um
and i sometimes think of this as like
the out pouching of a membrane i mean if
people remember looking down slides or
done microscopes or seeing slides of
um organic membranes of living tissue
they will often see that they have sort
of out pouchings called villi
or or that an amoeba has something
called a pseudopod that it can extend
and if you're in the middle of one of
those those
long things you can think you're
completely surrounded on all sides but
at the foot of it you're connected to
the mane
and i think that our consciousness is
quite rightly seems to us
um and it would be no good it had been
flooded with everything else going on in
the universal nothing original would
ever happen nothing would be creative
and i keep saying
the only way i can explain the cosmos is
through a deep
creative urge that's the most i can say
of it
and one that probably is connected to to
love
which is relationship anyway um
what i'm saying is that our
consciousness my consciousness whatever
it is my brain
is experiencing as consciousness is for
the moment
absolutely connected with my brain you
know if i get an injury in the brain to
affect the consciousness
and in in to go back to james's thing
about the vocal cords if he has an
injury to the vocal cords
his voice will disappear and so on so
but he he he and his thoughts and his
everything that were expressed through
that will carry on i i know it's not an
exact analogy another image i
i use sometimes is is of the the
consciousness in the brain
being able to divide and go around an
island so that
at a certain point in the flow of a
stream there may be two
seemingly quite distinct streams that
don't know much about one another
at that moment if you took a but it
moved 100 yards down the river you'd see
that they came together as they'd been
together before
and they weren't there for entirely
separate streams although it would be
perfectly reasonable
to talk of them as separate streams at
the time
but ultimately they are connected and of
course the image of the stream which is
the
the image that um that my
all time favorite philosopher heraclitus
said was at the heart of you know all
everything flows
um it is a brilliant perception because
the stream both
remains as a stream that passes my house
and it
will be there tomorrow morning with luck
as it is now but
it's also true that it's changing all
the time and even changing its
boundaries
a little and what goes on in it and so
forth
i recall you talking about heraclitus
and saying that it is
both that the stream is the same and
that it's you know
that you don't step in the same river
twice it's more like exactly
you're it's more like those are two
different modes of
being with the river or the stream okay
now see that's different then the
standard analytical answer would be
the wittgenstein which is while you're
playing different language games
and so it depends on what you mean by so
and so but you're saying you've changed
it from the analytical to saying no no
it depends on how you be
okay yes mind outlining that briefly or
as lengthy as you like for the audience
i think i was incredibly insightful
in a way it's another way of saying
something i said before which is that
it's not
either or or both end
it's both either or and both and
so it is both true that the stream is
the same stream
and that it is a different stream
uh each of these has a sort of truth and
in a either orchestral mind you can go
well come on which is it
but in another way you can say it's
perfectly coherent that it is
both not actually because
in some part as i've just suggested with
an image of an island
but all the time it is
one and the other and
there are many things uh in in life
uh and in the wider
structure of things it seems to me that
have this dual
not dual quality exactly but this
unwillingness to
to finally split it into it's got to be
this way or that
in fact the further you go towards deep
things the more you find that
opposites um come together and i know
i'm hardly the first person to have said
that but it still needs to be said
isn't that still very much needs to be
said sorry
is that why you said at one point that
the logical mind while it reinforces
itself reinforcing
at its extreme you would get to the
right mind
well i think it to the extreme it ought
to be able to encounter its own bounds
so for example in a way girdle
demonstrated that a certain kind of
entirely logical
thinking eventually demonstrates its own
limitations
and pascal said that reason is feeble
indeed
if it cannot see its own limitations and
don't forget that pascal was a great
mathematician and logician
so um i mean as well as being
a great spiritual thinker so if you take
the left hemisphere thing far enough
it will encounter its own self coming
the other way
and we sometimes see this happening in
the world that if you take a certain
point of view
far enough um if you take um
an intolerant attitude that's dogmatic
and
cruel on the right and
a similar one on the left you can hardly
tell the difference it's in the
mentality it's in an approach to the
world
um and you know by going further and
further away to the
right or the left you don't avoid
the fate that you're trying to avoid the
nemesis will come to you if you insist
on having a black and white either or
way of thinking
so we must for our own sakes get back to
seeing that it's a both and
world in which you may have truth on
your side and i may have truth on my
side and we ought to respect one another
and talk about it
in a grown-up way not um
vilifying hating and silencing people
but
listening to people who say things
different from ourselves
that's so fundamental it's how our
civilization got to
have a culture and now we're throwing it
away
anyway sorry it does distress me very
much
this this sudden rise in in the not
being shades of meaning
i think it's to do with the way we're
educated i don't think we're taught any
longer to think
there's a phrase in greek in classical
greek
men and then many
of the great philosophers of greek
they would say men on the one hand this
there on the other hand that and in a
way that was part of the way i was
taught to think that you should see
yes as good in that but there's there's
also something else to be said that's
you know you need to be aware of and
i i i've in the last year or two come
across
a couple of zen sayings that i like very
much and i think i might write a book
with one or other title and one is
yes but and the other is not always so
and that really brings on back into the
world of the right hemisphere because
the right hemisphere
thinks yes but it's the one that always
says
uh yes but hang on it inhibits headlong
action it's actually more intelligent
and it literally is a more
intelligent hemisphere in the sense that
if you have damage to the left
hemisphere damage to the right
hemisphere
overall damage to the right hemisphere
will drop your iq more than damage
oh that's extremely interesting i know
that you can function in the world more
adaptively if you have a left lesion
not the right lesion you can certainly
function more because your emotional
intelligence is not impaired and your
understanding of human beings is not in
bed
but your good old-fashioned cognitive
intelligence i
whatever it is iq measures is also more
highly dependent on
the right hemisphere than the left um
anyway there's a study by barbie at al
in 2013 where they looked at um
150 people who'd had strokes and had a
pre-morbid iq measurement
and looked at their post-morbid iq
measurement
and the and then they put the maps over
the top of one another
and where were the really key areas for
dropping your intelligence hardly any
was in the left hemisphere interesting
almost all of them are in the right
hemisphere which is not of course
again part of that bad old caricature
difference between the left and right
hemispheres well you know the right
hemisphere is all very well dear but
it's a bit you know kind of
not very reliable and silent but
yes but actually it's both more reliable
in the sense of more
likely to make the good decision and
more intelligent but anyway there we go
but let's say about inhibition because
you you you said to me earlier on and
then i actually i really must
stop i'm enjoying it so no no bless you
no i could i could talk to you all day i
wish we had time
um but i said early on
something about inhibition well here's a
fascinating thing
first of all the corpus callosum which
started up that's the
band of fibers that connects the two
hemispheres at the base of the brain
started out largely facilitatory in
other words it was largely
um conveying information from one to the
other hemispheres but it has now
come to the point where much of its
actual outcome
is inhibitory so much of what it is
doing is saying
you keep out of this you'll confuse the
picture i need to deal with this
and when the
mammalian brain evolved from you know
the mouse or whatever the shrew
up to ourselves if we can think of it as
a road upwards
um it involves more and more inhibitory
neurons
and mammals have more inhibitory neurons
primates have more inhibitory neurons
than other
non-primates and humans have more
inhibitory neurons than any other
primate
and the really important
neurons for uh
the effectiveness of carving experience
coming back to the idea that that as
we're like
carving as a statue in this in the stone
something only comes into being by the
the turning away of something else so
the inhibition of the this is discarding
something that might have been
brings the thing into me i'm getting
stopped
yeah sorry because you could you could
actually keep
i mean i could keep talking to very ages
it's lovely quick comment on that i was
always wondering if there's a more
precise marker of intelligence or
sophistication than the encephalization
quotient or the brain
to body mass ratio and i was wondering
if you can use the inhibitory neurons in
the proportion of them
i i think any of the any of the known
markers
uh has a little to be said for it and
quite a lot to be said again right and
one of the things again you know think
about the crow
able to solve all kinds of problems a
brain the size of a pee
though birds do have a higher
encephalization quotient than us
well there's a higher encephalization
quotient that is correct
but nonetheless the actual
number of possible connections is very
much smaller which is probably why
they're not
building um building things that are
destroying the world
okay this one comes from sam ford
nice one i'm a big fan of ian
mcgillicrist i think he's perhaps one of
the most important
thinkers of recent times he cites jung a
few times in the master in his emissary
and mentioned ewing in his first talk
with peterson i've always wondered
how well he thinks jung's ideas about
the different aspects of the psyche
map on to his own he gives a little
pulse amble it seems to me that maybe
the persona ego
and the left hemisphere may match up to
some degree
and that the unknown greater personality
of self matches up to the
union of the left and the right
hemispheres maybe
either way i would like to know his
ideas on how
jung matches up with his well
that's a a very nice question and a good
one
um i have to say right away that i've
not really
made any systematic study of jung
i read um modern man in search of a soul
when i was a teenager and it struck me
as a very important and powerful book
and since then i have i've read bits and
pieces here and there so i don't really
i wouldn't say i'm a paid up jungian or
anything like that
although i do find that uh jungians like
buddhists
and i'm also not a buddhist although i
have
great sympathy with both jungians and
buddhists and
they seem to come to my my talks and
write to me
so obviously in their probably better
informed minds
whatever it is i'm saying has resonances
and i'm always interested in those
i think the the key thing about jung for
me
i can't really talk definitively about
things like the
you know the ego and the animus and the
anima and all these things but
but i can say that his general
world picture is very sympathetic
from my point of view and one of the
most important points
which is something that he shared with
goethe
um was this sense that opposites
uh come together and that's something
that i do strongly believe as i
i've said earlier when we were talking
about that
um so yeah but i'm afraid i'm not really
in a position to
it's slightly like the freudian question
you asked about
you know can we line up the id and the
eager and the super ego with
i think to an extent you can but
and i'm sure that you know it's possible
to make good analogies
um between jung's uh
work which i don't you know as i say i
don't know the detail
of um i've always thought of him as a
very
um sympathetic soul basically um
so i'm afraid i'm going to have to
disappoint sam there
but the thing that interests me though
is you know that although
you see looking back over history there
are so many people
who uh long before even freud and jung
and who knew even less about
the structure of the brain than they did
have posited
something very like what i'm think i've
discovered and i'm promulgating
from the basis of modern neuroscience
it's very exciting
that in a way these these great
archetypes these images from
wise minds in the past they they had
intuitive understanding
of something that can now be more
objectively demonstrated
you mentioned once in your book about
the greeks that they had
some intimation about the left and the
right hemisphere
either one is for i think perception of
the other one was for
understanding that's right yes and and
it's fascinating
um that so long ago people were
speculating on the
the the um the uses of the two parts of
the brain
i mean what one has to remember is that
in in galen who was you know
one of the first great physicians he
thought that the brain was actually a
kind of um
air conditioning system he thought that
it
it helped the person lose excessive heat
so clearly they were very long way off
modern science but
i i do cite and footnote the sources for
i think the third century a.d
suggestions that the right hemisphere's
perception
and the left for understanding now
unfortunately
it's actually true that the right
hemisphere is better at both perceiving
and understanding
but one sort of knows what was being got
at the right hemisphere is definitely
better at perception
and at the sort of taking of things as
reality rather than
um having an idea about them in the way
that the left hemisphere has so
you know it is that is also remarkable
thank you for reminding me yeah
well thank you for pointing it out i
make extensive notes
okay that's another reason why i was
telling you before that this podcast is
killing me in many ways
in one way in a salutary manner
hopefully
in in one way it's destabilizing in
another it takes so much preparation and
hopefully the preparation shows
in the questions and um sometimes i read
the comments and
often they indicate that they do but i
always wonder how much am i
overextending myself
no no well look i mean let me say
quite genuinely that you do
your your questions are some of the best
um
they target very important areas and no
i think you're
you know from that point of view you're
one of the best interviewers that i've
i've come across
so thank you okay well thank you thank
you man
it makes me bless i'm brown you can't
tell but
but i am blushing okay joanne dong
says can you ask megilicrist about the
substitution effect from psychology
and its impact on the imbalance between
the right and the left
hemispheres over the course of western
civilization
daniel kenneman states in thinking fast
and slow
when faced with a difficult question we
often answer an easier one instead
without noticing the substitution thank
you
well yes uh
well first of all let me say about uh
daniel kahneman and
and the hemisphere hypothesis uh it
would be wrong to suppose that when he
talks about thinking
fast and slow he's talking about the two
hemispheres
um in a conversation that we had
he confirmed my impression that he's
talking about
more top brain versus bottom brain than
the
right versus left so the frontal cortex
of both hemispheres
taking more time being more thorough and
the posterior cortex of both hemispheres
being more likely to be
jumping to conclusions or going for the
familiar however having said that
your questioner does touch on something
very interesting
because research shows that
um the the left hemisphere jumps to
conclusions
and tends to see what it wants to see
in what is being presented or what is
being asked it will actually ignore
or just not hear or just not see things
that invoke something that it's not
interested in or not aware of
so in that sense uh our tendency to
give a fast answer to something we can
answer rather than a slower more
thoughtful answer
to something that would be
required deeper reflection that is a
left right
distinction so the left hemisphere being
the more superficial and quick and dirty
hemisphere on this and the right
hemisphere having
um more of a capacity to see
several sides to something to think more
carefully about it and to inhibit the
immediate response of the left
hemisphere
okay siren dudley hopefully i'm
pronouncing that correctly says by
positing an
absolute division between the brain
hemispheres aren't we already thereby
engaged in holy left brain thinking in
other words isn't the notion of
different sides quote unquote
confined to only one side of the brain
namely the left
yes i i mean sorry the answer to that
question is no
um i i have talked about this quite a
bit
i've certainly addressed it in the in
the
uh in the new introduction to the master
in his emissary the new
new edition that came out a year or so
ago but
i do also address it in in the matter
with things
um there's a sort of sense that you know
you're dichotomizing aren't you people
sort of say that
but um i remember your exact line about
this
because sorry to interrupt for the
people listening the preface alone of
the master and its emissary
is already one of my favorite books of
the past
few years the preface alone i remember
listening to the preface i had to listen
to it because i
i was driving and so on so the preface
alone
had me pausing so often and thinking and
i'm just wondering how the heck is ian
coming up with this
anyway if you by the way you can only
i would point out that there is the
preface i'm talking about is for the
the new version right 2019 onwards
it has a green cover so if your version
doesn't have the green
cover then that doesn't have the preface
but it's very nice that you say that
because actually somebody sent me a very
nice email
saying man i've just read your
preference and you know
it's worth buying the book just for that
so it's almost exactly what you said
yeah so but i try i try to i try to
encapsulate you know some of the
the questions and answers there
but you know in life there are things
that are false dichotomies and there are
some that are genuine dichotomies even
if there is a degree of overlap
so for example you know um bad drivers
versus
good drivers that's a false dichotomy i
mean it's a matter of degree and it's
all on the spectrum
and then you could take um some other
things like
um being a tree or being an animal you
know
um there is a kind of pond life that's
very hard to say whether it's actually a
a plant or an animal but nonetheless on
the whole we can tell the difference
between an elephant
and a tree and and this is the
this is a perfectly good dichotomy if
you like
so what i would say about this the
divide between the brain
is that i always start off very early in
any book
i'm talking about it and say yeah there
is a certain degree of overlap
that's necessary and important but
nonetheless um
don't reject the fact that there are
very startling differences
just because you have to have you happen
to think that
dichotomies are impossible it's you know
dichotomies can be simple but it can
also be simplistic
to reject a dichotomy if there is one
and in this case there is one and let me
just repeat because people don't find
this easy to take in
there is overlap there is overlap
and an example i give is um
between the culture and climate
of iceland and indonesia okay
so iceland's a very cold country
and its landscape its vegetation
even the the the kind of temperament of
the people
is bound to have been molded by its its
climate
indonesia has a different climate a much
warmer more humid climate
and again the vegetation and the history
and the culture and even probably the
temperament
is different but it is still true
that the hottest year ever recorded the
annual average
temperature in iceland was higher
than the lowest average temperature for
the year
ever recorded in indonesia so it's
perfectly possible for there to be
overlap
in things that are radically different
so
i'm sorry the questioner gets a no from
me on that one
all right actually that line
it's burned into my memory the line is
people don't like dichotomies because
they say dichotomies are simplistic but
it's also simplistic to dismiss
something just because it's a dichotomy
now that one i'm gonna take i will
credit you don't worry but i'm doing
interviews
i'm being interviewed because i'm
putting out a film soon
on the extreme left what makes the
extreme left
extreme on the political spectrum right
not because i'm a right winger
in fact i'm apolitical but because it's
it's difficult to analyze what's
extremism on the left extremism on the
right is just
it's it's blatant anyway i
well i think main stream on the left is
is also blatant but
and they as i said earlier on when we
were talking
they have an enormous amount in common
right exactly exactly so that's why i
was like okay that's the horse
shoe theory i believe in a nutshell and
that's interesting because the further
you run away from a point the closer you
get to it after a certain location
so it's like a circle right in some
cases that is absolutely true yeah
maybe you want to quickly comment this
is something i was thinking about as i
was reading your book
is is there a way of mapping the
hemisphere differences the left right
onto our left right spectrum maybe it's
inverted like the right brain is the
left and the
and the reason i was thinking about this
is because while the french revolution
is posed as a left phenomenon and they
espoused rationality and so on but
that's a left brain but then
on the other hand they loved russoian
thinking which seems to me to be more
romantic which is right-brained
so there's many contradictions i see and
i couldn't map them on directly and i
was wondering if you had any experience
or thought about this well
well to come back to the previous
question this is a case where it would
be simplistic
so any culture is a mixture of many
things
and what i say about this is easily to
identify
right hemisphere style thinkers on the
right and on the left
and left hemisphere style thinkers on
the right and on the left
so that you get thinkers that are
dogmatic uncharitable
angry mr right knows what's good for
people
you know that is your left hemisphere
type and there's plenty of them on the
left just as there are on the right
and there are thoughtful flexible
compassionate people
who don't treat people as belonging to
boxes or
categories or ticking something but are
actually
complicated human individuals with many
many facets to their
their experience to their personality
now that
that exists on both sides so
it's quite coherent i think to say that
no it doesn't map onto
right and left in politics at all
in fact in some ways you know the
interesting thing is if anything the
left hemisphere
is much more theoretical and the right
hemisphere is much more interested in
experience
and one way of thinking about the divide
between the political spectrum is that
the left end of it tends to prioritize
theories over the experience of history
of culture
whereas the right wing or the writer
wing of
of thinking tends to be very interested
in history and culture
and context and embodiment not in a
theory that on paper looks like it's
going to make
everybody happy so i think
there is an argument that if you had to
put it either way
i would associate the right spectrum
with
the right hemisphere and the left
spectrum particularly the extreme left
with the left hemisphere interesting but
but as i say i don't think that you can
make a a clean mapping no
right nietzsche to me was paradoxical
because he
repudiated rationalities and then that
to me puts him on the right
hemisphere as well as loved the passions
but then at the same time
had the will to power as his primal
motive at least toward the end of his
life
so then that's the left okay daigo pinto
can i just say something yes sure
quickly about that yeah
um i do want to get away from the idea
that somehow reason is
associated with the left hemisphere and
emotion with the right
reason is associated with both
hemispheres and so is emotion
they are both capable of being emotional
the left is actually more intemperate
less inhibited when it gets emotional
and the right hemisphere pl is plays a
very important
part in reason which is the coming
together of thoughtful
reflection on experience and even in
some kinds of logic it is actually
superior to the left so it's a very
complex
picture this is a good point for you to
delineate the difference between
rationality and reason
because i just use the word rationality
and i often conflate it with reason as
well
but in your book you do give i think you
cite the newest for reason
well i it struck me
that in most languages rather as we
don't
differentiate between this and canon we
just have one word to know
we also don't like many other languages
have a different term
for a sort of isolated abstracted
form formulation of rational processes
in the sense that a computer could be
programmed to carry them out
and reason which is often in conflict
with that
being reasonable means taking into
account
rationality but also taking into account
what one knows wisely from experience
and from living
and in german there's a distinction
between fishtant which is more like this
rather abstract theoretical reason and
fenunzt which is a kind of quality that
you get from being wise and living which
means you're able to reason but do so as
a wise judge in a court would do
i mean a judge in a court shouldn't
really be just applying rules in a
computer-like way but should be thinking
contextually and that is what we used to
mean
by reason and that's what we used to
think was the flower of education that
the reason for educating people
was they could think in this very
balanced flexible way
taking many sides of things into account
but in our world today where everything
is very much skewed towards the left
hemisphere
we tend to think of reason as like a
kind of rote
rationality and i think that's a huge
loss
so yeah you mentioned the judge and that
reminds me i had a
speculative question or speculative
thought about jesus who had an emphasis
on the spirit of the text versus the
text
and one is in keeping with god and the
other is pharisaical it's a literal
interpretation
and jesus said you keep with god you
take the spirit and that to me was more
right-brained
and then i wondered does that mean
there's a theological argument for the
primacy of the right hemisphere
well there is actually and i make it um
in the matter with things but it's it's
a long
argument and it's a it needs to reflect
on many many many things
but i can't wait to read that book man
but what i would just say is there's an
interesting you know how
um my vision is that the left hemisphere
is either or
but the right hemisphere is sort of both
and
well the left hemisphere tends to be
very given to the letter
of the law as you hinted but the right
hemisphere is able to see that sometimes
the letter of the law
needs to be respected as well as the
kind of spirit of the law
because the spirit of the law is
generally what one wants to find not
the letter of it but if a person
has relied on the letter of the law
because that's what it says then they
ought to be given some protection
under law because they did abide by what
the letter of the law
said they might find themselves still
open
to the criticism that they didn't
understand the spirit of it
but i think that a wise judge would take
both into account and it's not
necessarily one way or the other that
they would i think they'd depend
their judgment would depend on the
circumstances and the person and the
case
before them
i know i want to get to daigo's question
but you just said
i i please i have to interject with one
thought
pascal in your book you mentioned that
he had
a quotation about the whole point of
reason i believe it was reason not
rationality but
let's imagine it's reason that the whole
point of reason is to realize that
there's an infinitude of
more important aspects to life than
reason
and then i was wondering well what does
one say to the
retort that when giving and
when giving a reason to not use reason
you're still appealing to
reason so it's somewhat self-defeating
how do you get out of that
um i didn't quite catch the meaning of
your last okay
let's say you're giving let's say you're
explaining to someone here's why you
shouldn't use reason
alone or if it's rationality alone but
either way you're giving me
an argument and giving a reason to well
there are different levels of reason and
there's a kind of meta level of reason
and i think the meta level
the overarching view that takes in both
is usually the one i
would say is best associated more likely
to be associated with the
working of the right hemisphere and so
as i say the right hemisphere is no
stranger to reason
absolutely not um and
it would be a big mistake to say that it
in any way rejected it
but it's more likely to see the limits
of it because it's
it's able to stand outside of its own
viewpoint and see there are things that
it doesn't know which the left
hemisphere is very
bad at doing so it thinks i've got this
schema which will solve all my problems
i run them through
this mental computer and the solution
comes out which is the right answer
and the right chemists can say no there
could be many right answers
they're not you know they're not
necessarily compatible with one another
but they might apply in different
circumstances at different times with
different people
so to see a more nuanced and
more complex picture i think the right
hemisphere is the one that would be
using elements of reason
and there's nothing wrong with reason in
itself to show the limits of reason this
is really what pascal was saying
and you've just demonstrated that that
is that is okay
he made a distinction between what he
called geometry
geometers and espirifa
fine spirits and he says the fine
spirits
by the word fine he means subtle so
the subtle spirit is different from the
slightly bull in the china shop black
and white hard and fast
inflexible geometric spirit in which
he's saying you know you you you turn
away
you do a diagram and you've you've got
the answer whereas the
the esp he says can see
things understand things that can hardly
be put into words but are very very
important
now coming from a mathematician that is
a very imp and a very great
mathematician
that's a very important thing to hear
is this related to at one point in the
book you referenced that we need to
transcend utility and i always wondered
well tongue-in-cheek what's the use of
that
but also how does one transcend you is
this related to or is it not related to
it or is it all related because at some
point
everything's related no no it is it is
uh related
kurt but in the
i don't know whether you've got to a
chapter where i talk about shayla's
pyramid of values
shayla was a contemporary of
heidegger's but died much younger whom
heidegger called the greatest
philosopher in europe of his age
and he he focused on values more than
heidegger
and he had a hierarchy of values which
at the bottom is
things that are merely useful or
pleasurable the sort of things that
actually
any animal would would go for and then
there are the higher values that
transcend
those of pure utility and i think those
are the very important values that
render us moral beings and
give our lives meaning and that just to
be following
utility and pleasure is self-defeating
in fact by doing it very much more than
any previous
civilization has ever done we are
endangering our very existence as a
civilization
we're just grabbing things as they're
useful taking
courses of action because they're easy
and pleasurable
whereas when a civilization is a at its
height
it inculcates a spirit of self-denial to
a point
of you know a certain degree of bravery
of courage
of humility of
you know moral consideration of the
value of others
and that this is not the way that we now
think
i'm assuming then when you use the term
utility you mean in a short term
or short-sighted or self-centered manner
because
yes we could always say that we could
always reposition utility to be utility
for god
so that if we're acting in accordance
with our morals then that's useful for
the
group as the whole but that would be a
terribly debased way of thinking about
um one's attitude to god it's rather
like the old argument that if you
believe that you will go to heaven if
you're good
then you're just really basically
pursuing a good
for yourself but that is really to
completely stand on its head i'm not
saying there aren't people who can be
motivated wrongly in this way i'm sure
there are and were but i'm really saying
that a true understanding
of morality excludes the idea that
you're moral
simply in order to get a benefit for
yourself i mean that's not morality that
is a kind of
yes a kind of selfishness and and it's
what we mean by hypocrisy you know where
people
say things and do things in order to
look
good and you know um
[Music]
sound like they're something that
they're not
okay daigo daigo pinto says his book the
master in his emissary is one of my
favorite books about the brain if you
could sneak in one of these questions
i'd be appreciated
he has five sorry he has four i'm going
to briefly outline them and then you can
answer one
or two if you like okay okay so he says
a section on the book that deals with
evolution of the solid self
though he uses in brackets that i'm
using these words
on my own here i'm not he didn't use
these words but there would be a
non-unified voice or several in an
individual which could be interpreted
as an outside other being and then you
make reference to moses and the ancient
greeks or
and so on as hearing god's voice as an
example he said
could he elaborate on this and point out
other sources on the topic
that's number one okay so save that
maybe you want to respond to that
he'll number two he mentions that
language and the music have a common
ancestry
and then give some evidence for the
claim and i'd like to hear if he's
learned anything new since the
publication of this book
there's that okay so that's the other
voices
language and music then what are his
thoughts if any on chomsky versus like
off
ideas about language that's number three
and then number four
what does he think about objective truth
can we apprehend it
pretty much does that wow okay okay so
again to briefly
briefly outline the god and the other
voices that are internal but yes
perceived as such
number two is language and music and
then chomsky and then objective truth
well i think the first two i have
covered either in what i've said or in
the book actually to some extent
but the last two are both very big
questions
um and to me more interesting ones
i very much think like lakehoff and
johnson
about language and i find
chomsky's views i may simply not have
given them the credit that's due to them
of course
but i i find them less attractive
because they seem more
um schematic more programmatic more like
the
there is a sort of software in the
hardware that does
certain things whereas i'm a great
believer in
what one might call the power of
imitation in humans and i spend quite a
lot of time on
the fact that humans are particularly
good
at imitating um
not not just um copying but actually
imitating
and getting into the skin of another
creature
or another person and feeling something
about
how they are and why they are doing and
saying what they're doing
so i think language grows in this way as
i i've said
from a sort of a basic
sense that is embodied profoundly
embodied in
in movement in the voice in in music in
the voice
and the the business of breath
and that it is not really an abstract
code
uh it can become that
but it actually i don't know that
chomsky gives enough credit
to the way in which language is
constantly
um metaphorizing embodied experience and
takeoff and johnson very much do
show how every everything we say
has a reference that is understandable
in terms of the body and we can't get
deeper than that in a way
than our embodied experience um
it's where as wittgenstein said i hit
bedrock and my spade is turned you know
one can't dig down any further but it's
from there that that language comes
and i'd i've got time just to say a
little bit about the objective thing do
i believe there's objective truth
annoyingly i'm going to yeah i'm going
to say yes and no
um and i think we do yes we do to a
degree have access to it
um i i think very importantly that like
many other things
it's a journey as it were not an arrival
i mean it's not something we get and
then we have it
it's a cast of mind or disposition
for exploring life in the world
which enables one to have more solid
grounds for believing what one believes
so
i absolutely repudiate the idea that
which is a you know a devastatingly
destructive idea
and a very silly one that anything that
anybody says
is equally true because there's no
criterion by which to judge it
um yeah it's almost
beneath rebuttal but it's so obviously
wrong you know if i believe that
as as socal says that you that i can
walk out of the 22nd window of my
apartment sec 22nd floor window of my
apartment
and survive on landing i'm wrong um or
very likely to be so
um on the other hand
it's not at all true that there's a
a single truth that is the truth because
all truths are contextual
and that doesn't mean that every context
renders it completely different
there are trends and for me the
important thing is to see that the path
to truth is not a line
but a matter of circling or spiraling so
the important thing is not to say
i've taken this step now the next
logical step is this and at the end of
the road there will be truth
you might even say well i know i'll
never get there that's true but you know
at least i can see exactly where i'm
going
but i'm not sure that truth is of this
kind i think truth is of the kind
where you you look at something from as
many different viewpoints as you can
and when you hear somebody say something
else about it you don't just rule it out
and
you know dismiss it you think now let me
search for what's
the truth in that because there are
aspects of truth in it
and i sometimes quote done on this the
poet john dunn
17th century english poet one of our
great poets who who says
words the effect that truth is
like a castle that stands on a steep and
cragged hill
and who wants to arrive at it doesn't go
straight up
but has to circle round the hill to get
there and that image is a very useful
one to bear in mind in fact i return to
the image of the spiral path
in which it's not exactly a circle which
means that you just end up where you
were when you
when you when you when you get round the
circle but actually a spiral
whereby you were you you've come to
somewhere like where you were before but
the view is now different
a little bit like dias eliot's famous
thing about arriving where we started
from but
knowing it for the first time and and so
i think life is a series of these things
and the path of objective truth is to
commit yourself to this
process of spiraling around and learning
as much as you can about it and knowing
you'll never get the absolute truth
but you can get much much closer to
truth and that matters very much
so truth matters and it is not the case
that you know well i just see it
differently so
my truth's as good as yours your truth
may be as good as mine
it may be better than mine but it may
equally by the same token be worse
so you know there is meaning to this
idea
a very important meaning to it and i do
find
earphones very funny i don't know
something about my ears but they always
keep flopping out
um anyway there we are um
that's that thank you that's the sir
i appreciate it you should read
just as we go you should read this book
by douglas hofstetter your
your chapter on imitation reminded me of
it it's called surfaces and essences
it's about analogy
okay uh is that in the mind's eye or is
what is that
no no no it's it's all own book it's a
huge book just about how analogy is the
core of cognition
even the fact that when we imitate
he i don't believe he uses the word
memes but susan blackwell even points
this out that
blackmoore points it out that to imitate
is extremely complex
to copy is right but to imitate is
complex
you have to take the essence of it yes
no that's exactly right
and what's also nice about it is that
again the right hemisphere is better at
this business of getting into the skin
of somebody else and
understanding the complexity of it but
it is also
the one that thinks that understanding
is analogy
so that these when i talked about
mathematicians and scientists
having a sense of a form and
and then finding that through a
revelation or intuitional
insight they saw the solution to a
problem
that was by analogy not by going
well i'm nine tenths of the way there
down this path and if i just do a few
more pages of work i have reached it
nothing is an understanding in that way
we don't just gradually work our way
along a line
we we have to see and feel
analogies and this is how einstein
described his own
discoveries that he would play a piece
of music and he would ponder about it
then he'd get up from the piano and go
i've got it
and or at least his daughter i think
describes him in this way
so and he always said you know that i
don't think in words i think
in musical forms and muscular movements
well
how remarkable is that so anyway we
we've we've talked
an awful lot um
and have a drink get some rest well for
you i don't know what time it is
i got the chomsky itself it's a little
early for a drink for me but i'll get
onto it in due course and drink your
your very great health and i look
forward to talking again
perhaps in the year when you've had a
chance to take a look at the matter with
things yeah
thank you so much i keep wanting to call
you professor i was surprised that you
weren't a professor because
the the corpus of your of
of mastering its emissary is it's a huge
intellectual achievement
well i i'm a maverick and um
uh jung and freud were um doctors
uh i'm a doctor i like that real
my wife liked the advice that you said
about me taking some time off and having
a break
so we're likely going to do that after
the chomsky interview
okay have a great day very good i want
the audience to look up okay first of
all where can they find out more about
you
uh the best places to go is um
channelmcgilchrist.com uh which you can
just put in a
as an url or you can google my name it
will automatically
the main book of my thinking is the one
that you
referred to but in the next few months
i'm publishing
a very large book which is my attempt to
explain why
the whole way we think about ourselves
nature
the cosmos and reality is mistaken and
it's based heavily on the hemisphere
hypothesis
and i think it shows a way in which we
could go forward in the world
and flourish and survive rather than
come to um a disastrous end
so there we are i'd love to talk to you
again one day but uh
right now i'm gonna go and have a drink
okay go ahead go have a drink
at some point i did want to ask you
about cognitive behavioral therapy for
what i was going through but what i am
going through like i want to know should
i just be out of nature more
should i listen to more music i
definitely gonna stop or try my best to
stop being so self-conscious
and and let's say left brain i think
i think being able to be mindful being
out in nature listening to music
slowing down and doing precisely what
your left hand is telling you mustn't do
which is waste time
would be a terribly good idea i mean i
think that's such a destructive idea
that time is a resource it's typical
left hemisphere
idea that time is money as jeremy
bentham a man with
no right hemisphere detectable um to the
human eye
sad and it's this idea that we husband
time as material and the more we do that
the less time we have the more hurried
we are the less we inhabit the world at
all and then we die
so i think it's a very good idea to slow
down
and to learn to listen and not to be too
active
i mean i don't always take my own advice
i have to say yeah
well you're i don't know how you were
able to do that i
i have no idea how you were able to come
up with that book it you know 14 years
sounds like
quite a long time but as i have done my
own research
i feel like in 14 years i would have
come up with 20
of what you came up with so that's a
tour de force man
well i sometimes think the mice came in
the night and
wrote it for me yeah
okay thank you so much thank you please
get some
rest have a drink i i feel like in many
ways
this podcast is killing me because i
planned so i have so many pages here i
go
through such lengths to for each guest
but we can
hey we can do this again if you don't
mind i would
i would love to i don't want to i you're
too kind
i truly work yeah no no look what about
we do it again in say a year's time my
book will have come out you can yes yeah
we'll have another go that would be
great yeah great great okay where are
you by the way are you in l.a or what
i'm in toronto
toronto ah yes that's right
because yes because you said i i
attended the
the first showing of the film which and
that was the one in toronto
somebody had some sound engineer got a
very red face afterwards with it
yeah yeah that's right we could barely
hear you and i think
peterson had to talk to you over her
phone
[Laughter]
all right then love you too being your
guest thank you very much
again it was a pleasure it was a
pleasure thank you i honestly mean it
like your book is life changing at least
for me
and i think slowly it's going to dawn on
me or
the realizations that you've just
incepted or implanted thank you
thank you very much hopefully it's not
too destabilizing for me well
oh the very best have a great one thank
you
okay i'll try and be more embodied i'll
try my best because i don't i definitely
don't want to hear voices
okay have a great one man all right
thank you bye-bye
you